Okay.
Hey,
what'd we live,
Brian?
Yeah.
Check baby check.
Maybe one,
two,
three,
the Joe Rogan podcast,
but we're got a little bit,
excuse me.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off.
Do you want own for Free Al Magical?
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
And 50% off.
You'd think they'd be giving 50 here.
It's a solid number.
15% off.
All right.
Buckle up pitches.
Here we go.
Bad out now.
Magicals here.
Follow him on Twitter.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
How magical my friend.
Thank you very much for joining us.
Sure.
It's good to see you buddy.
Yeah.
Has Always,
and you came here with great news.
As you pulled up,
you said that you,
uh,
you were a correspondent on the daily show.
Yeah.
That happened and actually I did my first piece,
I think it was like two weeks ago.
That's awesome.
And,
uh,
it was a one of them,
one of the most incredible things because you want to be on that show,
that,
and part of something you really like.
I mean,
it's like you at the UFC,
this is something you enjoy and so you're a part of it and say,
now I'm,
I'm on.
Um,
I,
I go both ways on the daily show for,
in one way.
I love it.
I think it's a great show.
I love,
it's so smart.
You know,
some of his,
uh,
those,
the,
the breakdowns that he does and stories and news is,
they're just so brilliant and he's so good at it now and so comfortable at it
now.
He's my favorite talk show hosts.
Bye.
Yeah,
it's him and Jimmy Kimmel credibly to favorites.
Yeah.
Come on as well.
But he's so Jon steward,
so fucking smooth and he's so good.
It's sits like that show is like,
you know,
it's like,
it's,
to me,
it's like way better than being on Saturday night live.
And um,
in terms of like,
did him being,
it's loose and having a good time,
that's it.
I didn't want to.
Yeah,
we'll tell you.
Always tell you that when we stand up,
have a good time.
Right.
If you're just really,
yeah,
that's an important part of it.
I've done,
I did his show once and it was really cool I think at least once,
but I did it once when a fear factor was coming out and it was,
she was really funny.
He's just,
uh,
he's,
he's so fucking smooth and good at it,
you know,
the,
to be on that show is like,
God,
you just nailed an honor.
Yeah.
It,
it really is one of the coolest things.
It's like in to considering the past comics they've had on and comic actors,
Rob Riggle Cordrey sure.
And the people that they have on now and you know,
just go on and Lewis Black and a white Sanuk and just,
uh,
Larry Wilmore.
And so here are all these comics and it does an incredible amount for your
career.
And I'm still at the point we stand up is not a lot of people know me cause I
haven't been on anything that's really stuck.
Yes.
Oh,
a friend of mine went to see you a few years ago.
My Buddy David Hurwitz,
who's one of the producers a fear factor and he didn't know you.
Uh,
he went to see a,
there was a bunch of people,
some sort of a benefit.
I don't remember who the comics war,
but it was,
you see yours back.
You went up and I remember he called me up and he goes,
God,
I forget this fucking guy's name.
But he was so good.
He goes,
he was doing all this shit.
His kids,
I go,
Al Magical.
He goes,
yes.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
So he was,
he in this was,
you know,
this was years ago.
You're one of those guys to me that your,
your talent and like your,
your ability and how funny you are on stage it.
People haven't caught up to it yet.
You're,
you're,
you're fucking hilarious dude.
You're really,
really fun.
I really appreciate that because it's a,
I chose to take on doing longer stories.
Yeah.
And that's what I really enjoy doing.
What it takes a while to was you know what the bigger chunk,
like one line or is it common with the bigger chunk and they're hard to keep
people in the hook and then to say goodbye to him because you don't want to do
them anymore in new,
you're always hoping that another story comes off like,
oh like I'm posting,
Shit happens to me.
Quick stuff is so fun man.
It's really good.
Solid standup.
That's why I'm like,
you know,
you're where you are in the public eye.
It's a,
your talent far exceeds dot I think.
And I think a show like this is just going to let people see your stuff.
Yeah.
It already it comes,
come see our live.
Okay.
Cause God damn employee TV sets,
TV sensor like a commercial.
It's a commercial for the live show.
The live show is the real deal.
Sure.
And I do tend to,
I've been sort of snapping on people a little bit by interacting the audience.
Nothing
simple.
I'm the other day,
it's a,
you know,
and I insist on being a glutton for punishment and going to the store and
there's just a black girl on her phone.
Oh No.
And I address it right away.
She's not even looking up and I say,
hey,
Hey dawn,
she refuses to get off it.
So I'm talking to her the whole time,
but she's gonna make a point and be stubborn.
Oh my God,
I'm going to be stubborn at the same time and I'm not going to let her off the
hooks puts me like version and I can't help but address it.
So I think when you get in the live show is,
yeah,
that loose atmosphere where,
I mean,
and you've had me had a couple of these sounds.
Yeah.
Shows,
messages to that woman's phone was,
by the way,
this is your doctor.
You have breast cancer and your child's on fire.
They tried to say that a lot of times it was
sometimes when you catch me on the phone,
the girl,
well I don't have a sitter and I have my kid.
So we try to make you feel bad.
[inaudible] shit up fake kids.
They have to have,
you do have kids,
you should know you're being annoying to other people.
Yeah,
I have no problem.
People go outside.
I got in a big beef and
in south by southwest because some asshole head his iPad to out the day after it
came out.
Yeah.
Well he's sorta showing everybody.
Right.
Like got an iPad too and check it out.
Yeah.
So is he filming front row?
Oh
no,
he's not filming.
He's tweeting and we found out that he was tweeting to 32 people in the front
row and I go to and put away your iPad to everybody else.
He iPad.
It's nice.
I go,
if you're a reporter or a journalist and you were on an iPhone or iPad in the
back,
you're in the front row.
There shouldn't be this disconnect between Adi.
You know,
you're at a live show.
Quit look me in the face.
You know,
and don't,
I hate it when I'm at the laugh factory and people look into hung and monitors
that are on the side.
And so now there's this guy with his iPad two.
And so I had to be,
I told him I was going to put my foot through it.
Now he's going to put my foot through his face because he got shitty with me.
You have temper,
I forgot about that.
A huge temper.
You wanted him to hurt this person physically?
Uh,
yeah,
a little bit.
I mean,
I was trying,
then I tried to [inaudible] crazy man.
It was crazy.
He did jump us.
He did jump up.
Really?
Um,
I feel like I'm in a good position.
I don't think I thought at that point,
but I love the vantage point of a comedian.
Like I said,
why don't you and I need to be able,
they'd have to go down low and then immediately you would get the first shot
off.
Yeah.
So it was a big crazy guy.
You said he was big.
No,
you should little foreigner.
They little four around at fucking IPAD.
That's what it was for.
This is Al Madrigal.
Yeah.
Oh,
I pretty much get lumped into the,
the Latino comedy thing that you did for a little while.
I was still,
I mean they're getting a lot of those shows and the opportunities that,
because I feel like it's like with Greg Geraldo who I loved as a comic and I
thought she's incredible.
Um,
you know,
he was a comic period.
Just calming.
Yeah.
That's why I didn't even know I was Latino comic until I fucking moved to La.
Like all this chocolate Sundaes shows of
Guido Guido show a few times and um,
at the comedy store.
But it's like,
man,
I don't want to be on the show at these fucking guys just because we share some
patch of dark where our grandparents,
I just,
uh,
yeah.
I,
I just think comic first and those guys also a lot of Latino comps,
she ended up doing those same Latino shows over and over and over again.
And then when you finally get to put in a situation that they're ill prepared to
handle regular people,
you know,
they can't,
that aren't specifically Latino.
I was so glad that there's a lot of different styles though.
I'm glad that there's black comedy.
I'm glad there's Latino comedy.
I'm glad because it's all,
it's very interesting seeing,
you know,
with different cultures and different,
different sections of society,
what they laugh at and what they think is funny.
And when they,
when they cross over when they don't,
cause this is a lot of really funny white comics that go up in black rooms and
eat dicks.
Yeah.
And it's just,
it's a different fucking thing.
They don't,
first of all,
they don't want,
it's,
it's a,
it's very hard to pull out of a hole in a black audience.
Like once you go into that hold,
the booze start coming and the get off,
get off.
It's like you,
if you're not prepared for that,
if you haven't done a lot of black shows,
like if you bomb one of those shows,
like
good thing.
It's like everybody's grew up watching the Apollo.
Yeah.
And they at stand up and they're waiting for the guy with the clown and the cane
to come out because horrible.
So they're not shy about going,
oh my God,
it's in a weird,
like a whole group of people.
We'll collectively decide to be haters.
You know,
like that's,
that's the most ridiculous thing ever.
That you're all bullying and his and get off,
get off and they'll attack.
Like they want dudes to fail.
They want dudes to fail.
It's part of fun.
Wesley Snipes,
hypes
movie.
I was watching it.
It wasn't new Jack City.
It was something like he was a drug and he was
going to court,
I think it was Robin givens.
So we need to look this up.
He goes wrong,
gives me,
he goes,
I just want to hang out with you baby.
How I want to go to the Apollo and Buddha comedian,
you know,
that's what we'll do.
And so that was his pickup line.
He goes,
we'll do fun things like who?
The comedian?
Yeah.
Yeah,
the comedy store.
It was a fun place for us all because there's no one watching that place,
you know,
in,
it's good and it's bad.
It's good in that,
you know,
you're forced to deal with this chaotic world.
That is,
that place is an police comedy club.
I ain't died Paris at one point.
I heard the stories about him having chicks on stage.
It's got a naked women.
I've seen that.
And then there's no manager at that point or shout where the manager's D's do
drinking an hour ago.
Nobody gives a fuck or didn't at one point in time in that place.
There was one time when Joey Diaz took his pants down and the,
you know,
the original room has a curtain behind it.
I told this story before,
there was a girl named Judy,
since Yachty,
oops,
shouldn't have said her name.
Damn.
And she was on stage and Joey was behind her and every time she would hit her
punchline,
Joey would open up the curtain and show his balls and the fucking place she was
killing and she was on stage like so confident.
All of a sudden you could see like light up,
like it was the best set she's ever had.
She was just fucking nailing every Joe.
She's going crazy because of Joey's balls are sticking out of the curtain.
That's as you can go through the backbone and sneak up behind you to those
curtains.
You could,
you could go,
there's a total back way to get on stage there because you know the old days
they didn't go on stage through the room like we do.
They would go on stage through the back door here.
Yeah.
That was,
you know,
there was like a serious nightclub that Ciro's nightclub when an awful feeling
though finding out it was Joey Diaz,
his balls and night.
Your comedy though.
Can you imagine that?
That's a gut feeling will sort of,
yeah,
but together it was really funny.
You know like I've heard joke was a four,
you know Joey Diaz has brought it up to nine balls.
All of a sudden it was like one of the best jokes ever.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if you heard,
are we allowed to talk about what Jody is just got?
I don't know if I'm allowed to talk about what is that?
[inaudible]
has got a role for a kid's show,
like a live action kid show.
And I don't want to go too much into,
cause I'm not allowed to know if I'm allowed to say it,
but I was thinking,
what if he becomes like this huge celebrity in the kid world?
So now he's like at the airport called,
what the fuck?
I got a little kid come up.
What's our Ah,
hey tracking is and ponies.
Can you imagine having him having to act like shift gears,
shift gears.
He's gotta Watch out to signing autographs for eight year olds.
Wow.
The idea is this,
it makes me laugh.
Thinking about that though,
he did these great and you don't want to,
I'm not sure how much time he spends around your kid,
but he was great.
I ran into him on a lot when we were both filming a TV show and my son was two
maybe at the time and he goes,
come via a little red zone.
Uncle Joey's got take care of you.
Come on.
My son looked up at her and he goes,
this guy's hilarious.
Like he looked at her and went right to him and Joey was holding him and it was
like the,
the cutest things.
Like he'd let go uncle Joey like,
damn,
my son is playing with it.
And just,
it was like,
oh my God,
he's great with kids.
And he'd perfect for a kid show nine capsules.
Joey has nine cats.
How many are you allowed to have?
Right.
He lives in an apartment you shouldn't have mentioned busted.
He is.
He did.
He did move to a house or is he still in an apartment now?
He's in an apartment and I think he got to where?
Cats or something like that.
Yeah,
he got 11 wow.
That is nuts man.
That is nuts.
I was just talking to these guys.
I'm allergic to check my worst nightmare.
Crazy.
You,
you telling me that you had to take a allergy,
allergy medication before you came to my house?
I only have two.
And you have to and the end,
then we shave them and then take them to a groomer.
So the gets less hair in the,
in the ward.
And the last time I was here,
I didn't take an allergy medication and it wasn't actually even that bad.
But 11 cats for certain God,
six and I think it's a one is a two bedroom,
two bedrooms.
I think it's two bedroom.
Yeah.
You know how everyone's allergic to cats,
right?
And like every single person in the road is allergic to cats.
It's six different levels.
It's the Dander.
But here's a Whoa,
whoa,
everyone's allergic.
Everybody.
You sure you were saying allergic like as an allergic reaction to everyone.
If you take a scoop of a cat dander,
no matter who it is,
if you somehow collected cat dander and you put it in your eye or something like
that,
you would have in the allergic reaction to it and you real.
Yeah.
But I,
I,
you know,
those are little hairballs once in a while we'll,
that will fall off a cat when they,
it hasn't been shaved recently I had one on my pillow and I slept on it and I'm
not allergic to cats too to any extent really.
But I had that and I slept on it right in my eye.
My eye swolled up for two days.
I,
it looked like I got punched in the eye over the week,
over the weekend.
And it's just now coming down.
I don't know if it's still looks at when you decided you'd better calling a
professional.
Yeah,
exactly.
I call it an it professional.
I'm trying to find this cat dander thing online to see if that's true,
but it just be nasty.
Anyway.
It would give you,
if it got in your eye,
you don't necessarily think you could call that an alert.
There's definitely,
there's definitely different degrees in your iPhone and I think almost
everything would fuck your idea,
but isn't allergic.
Like it gets in your skin and you have a reaction.
Look at me.
I can't breathe.
I mean,
that's why I'm holding this up.
Throat swells up and my eyes start to really water and um,
you know,
I'm screwed in my mind.
He starts hearing welts.
We had a real issue once on fear factor and one of the very few we did where we
found out that if you're allergic to shellfish are also allergic to roaches and
we,
yeah.
And we fed these people,
these giant Madagascar hissing cockroaches and a one dude,
his,
his throat started closing up.
Shit got really scary.
He imagine if that was the wrong person,
you could have easily killed somebody.
They monitor them,
you know,
they have medics and they also,
I don't know how that could have slipped by though.
What it sounds like you have to know,
you have to find out what is the latest on that you were on Perez Hilton
yesterday or today or something like that.
If president and said something nice.
I appreciate it.
Thanks dude.
Um,
yeah,
uh,
they,
fear factor is going to come back.
It's going to come back for 10 episodes.
So I don't know if I'm doing on the chill network is then no,
no.
It's going to be on NBC saying,
Oh wait,
I heard that they're thinking about getting rid of the bees stunts though.
No,
no,
no.
That's not true.
So if they do it,
I'm sure they're going to do it the way we did it.
It's all the same team.
It's a CUNY and Dave Herwitz sin and Rupert Thompson,
the director,
they know exactly what the fuck they're doing the reruns for doing so well dad,
what they did,
they just got it down to a science.
Rupert is a bad ass director and and and [inaudible] is an awesome producer.
They've been doing those shows like dog eat dog and you know he does like all
those,
you know like what does that wipe out and like they have those shows down to a
science.
They wouldn't fuck with it.
What they would do with fear factors just make the stunts were cooler looking
now,
now that there's HD,
I mean you can do some shit with cameras that we can never do back then.
It have to do that show though.
That fear factor to a lot of people I think is you.
I think that's what made the show that's very flattering but a sort of just had
fun with it and helped it along.
It would have been crazy weather I was there or not.
If somebody else was there that was fun.
It would have been there kind of crazy.
But you can never,
you can always speculate what shows would be like without the original house,
but it's like,
yeah,
you know,
and they'll probably get somebody that looks kind of like [inaudible] his new
album.
It would bring up Mario Lopez is what we always said.
Mario Lopez.
Yeah,
totally.
But he's one of those do is it can host anything.
Yeah,
handsome bastard.
I don't know.
I don't know what if I'm going to do it.
I,
I'll tell you what though.
if you had asked me after fear factor was over,
like what?
I thought I would been like,
God,
I'm done.
I want to do other shit.
But having a few years off of it and then all this talk about doing it,
I'm like,
wow,
that might be kind of fucking crazy.
That might be crazy to just do still a few episodes.
I think it's,
I love this shot and then near the end I got kinda tired of it.
But now I crave it again.
I will see it on TV and I will rewatch it and it's like watching it for the
first time.
I think it's fun.
Yeah,
I think it could be huge.
I think so.
I think it's,
and I think you know a lot of staff there do as well.
I mean you've gone off and done other things.
It has attracted is a lot.
I mean do you probably have a lot more people coming to the show and you'll
bring a lot to it as well.
It's not just that the show is iconic,
it's a,
you know,
I think you've done a lot of shit since then.
Dad would have a new audience looking at.
Yeah,
maybe.
But you know what the show,
the difference in the show in anything else that I do is that everyone can watch
it.
One of the appeals of the show was that is ridiculous.
You know,
for an adult,
it's a ridiculous show.
You know,
you'll be watching going,
this is fucking ridiculous.
Well.
It's ridiculous.
The little kids too.
It's fun to them too,
so it's fun for like old people.
Like you can watch it with your whole family.
That's it.
That's what wipeout is.
She said,
my kids love themselves.
Overweight lady do it for the podcast.
It's second you do that for the podcast.
The podcast would blow the fuck up.
Maybe we'd get too much scrutiny.
Maybe that's the issue because I'm under scrutiny right now for the,
my use of the word country.
Yes.
It's called Cunty Gate 2011 nice.
Putting
her why on anything really sweet.
I thought it was sweet.
I look at the word as if it's like the word bitchy and I realize from the
reaction of all these different people that other people do not share my
opinion.
Do we have a kid visit from England?
It he dropped it.
I mean seriously.
Many times.
Yeah.
They just,
they won't stop throwing the Y on it.
It's like saying somebody,
well it's like her writing is what I was describing.
The,
the writing is country on it,
but I said she,
I said she's all kinds of country.
I meant what is representative of her is all I know of her is her writing.
You know,
she is a human being.
She might be a very nice person.
She might just be misguided in the way,
this type of style of insulting writing that she does.
But it's bitchy and I don't,
and I don't like it and I should have used the word bitchy cause that's what I
meant.
But I wrote the word country and everybody said,
Oh,
you're calling a cunt.
I'm like,
that's not what I did.
But it Kinda is,
but it's not.
You know what I mean?
To my circle of friends and the way the people that I hang out with,
we throw country around like a beach ball,
right?
I mean we are,
we're always using the word country testy.
It's like,
to me like wouldn't,
they would never say that,
but I don't think that's,
he's my list.
There's not,
not,
it doesn't make molesta getting cuter.
I'm sure she's called worst things in bed.
The whole thing,
it's she what,
what she's doing is negative.
But what I did was negative too.
There was probably a better way of handling.
It's a message board by the way.
Calling your content.
Yeah.
It wasn't like I did an interview,
I would just wrote something on a message board and what I was,
the only reason why I wrote it is because this one guy,
um,
I think he calls himself the Skywalker who's on this uh,
mixed martial arts.com message board had this very eloquent way of describing
what was wrong with this woman and her style of writing.
And it was just Bingo.
And so I wrote boom.
And the whole thing was all about an interview that Quentin rampage junior did.
Is he a junior?
Did I just make that up?
Jackson?
Shit.
Why did I say junior?
Oh cause I was watching Roy Jones all day today.
It's like what the fuck would that come from?
Quintin Jackson,
Quentin Rampage Jackson.
Not fucking God damn it.
Eventually is this going to happen?
So this doesn't diminish my point.
Consulting,
not by choice,
but anyway,
a rampage is doing an interview with this woman and he,
he jokes around about a motorboating or like getting his head between her tits
and I didn't even see it.
It's fun.
You know,
I'm,
I'm sure it's ridiculous.
We probably should watch it to see how ridiculous it is.
But um,
what I was responding to is just this woman in her writing and wasn't really,
and,
but I could have done it a better way.
I you're calling someone country is not the real,
you know,
sometimes I get lazy dude when I respond to something.
I just wanted it as chicks,
all kinds of country.
I don't think I'm going to have to explain myself.
I don't think,
you know,
I just feel like I'm just posting something on a message board.
We're all just hanging around.
It's like a virtual street corner.
When you do post something on a message,
boy,
you expect that.
I mean,
who's look how many people are really looking at that as well.
There's mixed martial arts was a very popular message board.
Take it out of the message board and then use it against you in other bodies and
call for me to be fired.
Call for me to be suspended,
call for me to be fine people.
I don't know.
And I did apologize before any of the shit hit the fan.
I actually went,
a few people started getting upset at me.
I actually apologize for these use of the word country cause I said,
you know what,
I,
it's probably something from my standup comedian vernacular that I don't
perceive how it,
how you're perceiving it and I don't mean it how you are.
You're perceiving it from me.
So that's what I tried to explain.
But I also tried to say in the same,
uh,
apology that,
listen man,
you're putting some negative shit out there.
There's a reason I'm responding to you like this.
I'm responding to you like this cause I've read disrespectful things that she's
written to fighters.
She will just disrespectful thing to Tim Silvia after we lost.
And that kind of shit really pisses me off.
That snarky rude.
You know,
that that style of insulting journalism.
I don't like it.
If you don't take it as a place in mixed martial arts,
cause mixed martial arts is a crazy fucking sport.
And in this sport,
a person literally risks their health.
They get out there,
they train.
It becomes the focal point of six to eight weeks of their fucking life.
And then they get out there and in front of everybody in,
you know,
these little shorts,
they,
they'd go out and they throw their fucking bones at each other.
And to win is the most incredible thing ever.
And to lose is the most devastating thing imaginable.
It's like to lose is like the death of a dog.
That's what it's like.
It's like that kind of pain.
It's like this unstoppable pain,
emotional pain.
So a lot of these guys,
these guys get,
they get their ass kicked.
Maybe they didn't train so hard,
maybe it didn't go so well,
but then they have to read some disrespectful bullshit by someone who's never
fucking competed by someone who's never put their ass on the line by someone
who's never thrown their body into a cage for everyone else's entertainment.
I think if you make fun of that and you,
you,
you mock them,
fuck you.
You know,
You're not getting it.
There's a,
there's a way to say that someone's doing something wrong.
There's a way to say this guy,
here's the bottom line.
He's a very talented,
but he needs to get in shape.
He's,
he's fat.
That's,
let's be realistic about it.
There's that,
which is just,
you're,
you're making an assessment of someone's ability and what they need to change
and what they're doing wrong with their diet are there.
But when you just get snarky and shitty and insulting,
that shit drives me fucking crazy.
It just drives me nuts.
Cause only douchebags do that.
And they only do it because no one's ever told them that they're being douche
bags,
you know?
So I feel like it causes more negative energy to let shit like that slide than
it does to bring up.
And I make these judgment calls and I just call someone cunty.
I really probably shouldn't do it.
And I did apologize to her because like I said,
I don't,
I don't mean it the way they're perceiving it.
I mean [inaudible] the guy can be country too.
We can all be cunty countries.
Just like your net talk.
It's so different.
That's five years.
In five years,
the president will be saying in speech,
you know constantly,
if you run
for brethren,
fuck.
Maybe after Sarah Pailin does standard.
Yes.
Solo president,
Red Band 2024 look at that and get that dude from New York that accidentally
tweeted out a picture of his cock.
Did you see that shit?
I mean,
we're going to have presidents saying conti on the fucking TV.
This is ridiculous.
It's going to get to a point with the transparency of the world right now that
one of two things is going to have to happen.
Either people are going to actually have to actually become real nice people or
they're,
you know,
or no one's going to be president.
I mean,
if you're going to be able to see and to a person that's very fucking soul,
eventually you know,
you're,
you're going to know everything about them.
It's like as we get closer and closer to each other with Twitter and Facebook
and facetime and we're getting closer and closer to each other and it's going to
eventually reach some fucking crazy point where we're all sharing each other's
minds.
And when that happens,
you know,
we find out what creeps we all are,
who the fuck is going to be president then who the fuck is going to be president
then?
No one's going to want it.
What to think about the shit that Kennedy got away with,
right?
Everybody knows that Kennedy was banging Marilyn Monroe and he was a womanizer
and his family came from moonshine running.
I mean,
they had like this crazy fucked up pass.
They were there,
basically had an organized crime past their,
their whiskey runners back during the,
you know,
that's where they made their money.
They made their money during,
uh,
the prohibition.
So we,
if that was today,
cause you imagine,
could you imagine some womanizer who's,
you know,
whose family was an organized crunch.
Do you imagine for a second that guy like Kennedy would have a,
a brief chance of being the president?
I mean,
while he was probably one of our best presidents ever,
right?
I mean as far as everybody loves to Romanticize it because he died,
but God,
he made some brilliant speeches.
Matt,
we were friends we're talking about the other day.
It's like,
do you really think the CIA hasn't learned how to turn on somebody's camera on
their Mac book pro?
They knew how to look at that,
that hacking group that did the PS three,
the lust sec guys or whatever they're called.
They hacked into like,
they've been hacking into all these websites lately.
Like you'd be followed their Twitter.
It's kind of scary how awesome.
He's our mean,
uh,
how talented these guys are,
are they are fucking with the FBI.
They fucking Hack Nintendo the other day and they loved Nintendo so much that
they didn't want to do anything.
So they just said,
hey,
we love you too much to do anything.
Really.
Here's how we got.
Okay.
How do you not respect that?
I'm not saying I'm pro hacker on entirely,
but I respect the fuck out of that move.
Yeah,
but what's up with tendo?
They make awesome shit out.
Keep them in business.
No,
but that's crazy.
And then the apple today announced all this cloud based Shit,
which is scaring me to death because now what they're pretty much saying is
everything like you're late,
all your photos,
your all your music,
all your documents.
The last time you saved something on your computer,
you can do it on one computer and then go to another computer,
have the exact same shit on your computer and it's all based on the cloud
wireless data system.
What if you accidentally lose your laptop and somebody gets to turn it on and
sees all your documents,
your photos,
your videos.
We're going to see some fucking crazy shit coming up now.
I mean they,
apple,
if apple was smart,
they would have some kind of window that's on your computer that shows how far
away each one of your devices is at all times that I was using that the other
day.
On Your iPad you can get,
you can lock everything and crack everything.
Yeah,
you track,
but have it be a part of the operating system where it has some kind of security
issues like that build in is so just in case,
if you don't realize your iPads in Mexico right now,
that you know,
you could see it kind of like a graph.
You know what it means,
some kind of meter or something.
It was telling me about these yesterday about this,
uh,
this guy has my PC or this guy has my laptop.
Did you know about that at all?
It's like,
this guy has my laptop and there's software that you can put on anything that
you did a PC or Mac where somebody steals your shit and then they go on to log
on and go to the Internet in your camera comes on and they take a picture of,
yeah,
there's a whole website about this guy that lost his camera and it shows like,
like it's a whole story book of like this Indian guy or something like that.
And he's like never wearing shirts.
Oh.
So it didn't seem to be a girl lost her.
She lost her cell phone and she had a bunch of naked pictures on it and the guy
texted those naked pictures to everyone and our contacts.
I knew her about that.
This one?
Yeah.
This is really recently.
Some girl,
uh,
I think it was a droid phone.
I don't remember.
Don't sue me.
George Bush and Dick.
What an asshole.
You know what the attacker should've done?
It's fucking hacked MTV and stop that whole movie award.
Shit.
Have you been,
did you watch that?
That bullshit.
Nowadays they MTV movie awards.
Every single movie was twilight,
Best Kiss,
best actor,
best comedy or best,
but it was,
it's pretty much listen to mother fucker watching MTV.
So surprised it's for little girls.
It's like how old are you son?
No,
but I do like movies.
Okay.
Listen,
the Oprah movie club would be completely different than the Joe Rogan movie
club.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh Shit.
That I would love.
She would hate shit that she would love to.
I would hate,
it's all 14 year olds,
bro.
You're talking about empty fucking fee.
Oh,
I absolutely agree with such bullshit.
You know we need the good hackers don't there?
We should nuke them.
The alien should come in and invade.
I didn't even know it was on.
I just turned it on and watch it,
but it's pretty ridiculous.
I went to the Party for that MTV movie.
He worked at the after party.
Sweet.
How much the case sex did you have?
Quite a bit
from me.
The best part about that was you struggled.
Struggled through the word a little.
Oh,
I was thinking of it.
Perfect case.
It was like,
it was like,
is he slipping here and you got to fall through.
That was awesome.
Me and my wife and then her boyfriend to,
she Brodie talking to a Rod.
That was exciting.
Oh really?
He's been in his glory.
It was wonderful.
He was a really,
did you see
me talking to a Rod?
So he knows me and then a red is easy,
was here.
So we were all,
uh,
and I,
but it was,
it was funny seeing sandy celebrities and it gossip and yeah,
we saw those twilight people who were at a party and we left pretty early.
It was weird.
W The one toilet guy,
Edward,
or I don't even know his real name,
I just know his character's name,
but he kind of went off on Reese Witherspoon in a weird,
creepy way.
He like said something about how he was in her when he was a kid.
He was in a movie with her and she was directly responsible for getting his park
cut from the movie while giving her an award for like best chick of the year
award or something like that.
So he kind of like called her out on being an ass in a movie together.
And then there were seven years later they were in a movie.
But she's like,
he's like,
she doesn't know about this,
but that's so silly because like,
you know what if he sucked,
what do you mean she's directly responsible?
How could be really good?
He's probably just trying to be funny and he really went together or something.
I mean,
oh,
maybe it's an inside joke or it's just one of the bad writing that was done for
somebody who writes all the in betweens,
you know?
And for the movie awards,
that's a gig where somebody has to write.
Some people do like to be victims of God.
Damn.
I've talked to so many guys that you know,
I went out for that.
Oh,
I got fucked over by the casting director.
Like what?
You know,
like you get a dwell on the negative shit dudes will tell you.
No,
I got in his fucking casting directors.
Yeah.
It just never really liked me.
Just really,
it was my time.
The other guy totally chases her ass,
so I get fucked.
Like whoa.
Same people who are just making external courses for everything bad that happens
to him was never your fault.
It's always the casting.
It's always my,
you know,
the car or train or they always have some sort of a person or thing to blame.
Yeah.
Those guys are brutal.
Those guys are so brutal to have conversations with.
You don't realize that they're that guy until it starts and then you're stuck.
You know,
like,
oh Jesus.
Like what do I say?
Do I disagree with him?
Well,
what do I say?
Come on man.
You know,
own up to yourself.
Stuck in annoyance.
Never.
Yeah,
I do the opposite.
It's always me.
Like some of my dad would go on to school,
would yell at us and we ever gotten in trouble at school or there was a problem.
It was definitely our fault and the teachers,
right.
100% of the time.
And I was at,
and it was always the line.
That's what I was raised with is like,
yeah,
it's probably me.
That's better.
Yeah,
that's better when I'm playing.
It's like any Sebastian's,
I just watching Sebastian had a nice like,
um,
you know,
he goes talking about going to pink berry and then he goes in and he goes,
he goes to Sam
[inaudible].
He goes,
if I,
if I got the wrong fucking ice cream,
I fucked up.
Let me,
I'm going to fucking sample of green tea.
He has a great bit and everything.
All of his bits or just like,
I fucking just get everything on my fucking sandwich.
If I don't like it,
I throw it out the window.
What the fuck?
My pickle
take the allotted amount.
You still a fan of easy?
Yeah.
Have you had him on the show?
No.
Oh yeah.
He's hilarious.
It's way in all of you know of this bit's okay.
But anyway,
but this is back to that.
It's like,
okay,
you don't blame other people and happy people are so fucking nitpicky and it
gets us back to this whole country thing.
Yeah.
Um,
because people loved,
it was Snape.
And also as for a critic or any reviewer,
it's much easier to be a critic and say something back.
Those things write themselves.
It's also people really enjoy being in a conflict where they don't have any
stake is almost like a grand distraction that we have with a lot of gossip.
People get really deep into other people's lives and other people's fuck ups and
other peoples.
And what it seems to me is like,
I think it's a basic human nature that we have where our real life is.
It's very uncomfortable to focus on,
especially if we're not happy with it.
So we spend a lot of time focusing on other people's lives and a lot of time and
it actually becomes like there's a,
there's a whole industry behind it,
you know,
the TMZ style industry or there's like MMA has like similar sites that do
stories like this and make this a big deal and try to get everybody involved in
it.
It's like they love like controversy.
They love like they love like the,
the Shit disturber yeah.
Shit.
Disturber but it is,
but I support them because it is an interesting thing to watch.
It is.
I like watching reality TV.
I like watching the mob wives.
I like watching the real housewives of New Jersey.
I know what they're doing.
I know that they're showing me crazy shit and locking me into this.
Nothing,
but you know,
if I like it,
I like it.
She works for Geo City sports or what?
Yahoo Sports.
Right.
I don't care.
I don't care where she works is that she works for one of those places.
It's not even about her being silly.
He's being silly.
It's,
um,
the,
the whole thing behind it all is,
you know,
people,
not people not like recognizing someone's intent.
You know,
people making this,
this hot button word such a big issue and people getting so politically correct,
you know,
it's God,
it's so weird.
Everybody wants everybody,
you know,
in trouble for saying the wrong thing,
which is like a,
can we just be nice to each other and just don't be cunty can we just do that
instead of worrying about the word Conti and someone's saying it,
sending everybody with any words instead of that.
How much is stop being Kentucky?
Can we just,
then there'll be no need for the word [inaudible] if nobody was being conti.
No men,
no women.
Just get it together.
We're
getting there though.
Don't you think?
I mean like I just heard a tap a tio.
I think it was commercial or something like that on,
on,
on the way here.
And it was just like an old conti.
There's this old lady Capulet to his old lady.
Like I put that shit on everything,
but they'd beeped out shit.
But it was like I put that shit on everything,
but it was like,
oh,
that's so close.
Yeah,
I know,
right.
It's so close.
I always wanted to have that as a website are rated commercials where you could
go to my website and I would do like fucking lever 2000 like you should probably
like shit,
hey this,
you know,
and just really nice and candid,
candid commercials where it was just
swearing.
I think eventually the world will be accessing the Internet on television's on
radio's,
on car radios.
So you will be able to have those commercials.
I mean,
look,
we do a commercial for the fleshlight at the beginning and the end of every show
and it's,
it's,
I mean that is a,
it's a commercial,
you know,
I mean we can say whatever we want.
Go Fuck it,
shoot loads in it.
It's awesome.
I mean that is the r r rated commercial and it's on the Internet and because
it's on the internet,
nobody can tell me,
you know,
you can't tell me it's offensive.
Will you?
Eventually everything will be the internet.
It's these little regulatory bodies that are hanging in there now.
They're not going to be able to hold this fucking thing together.
Stick your fingers in the dam.
That is the Internet.
Good luck.
Fuck.
Oh,
you got no goddamn chance.
They can't even keep this fucking Sony playstation shit in line.
These mother fuckers,
there's a little geniuses out there and they can,
they can find their way through anything connected online,
anything that's got a network,
they can find a hole and creep in and send a picture of some guy pulling apart
his ass hole and make that your desktop.
Okay.
If you don't have to,
can you?
You're silly.
You're a silly person.
There's some crazy motherfuckers out.
No,
no.
Right.
I mean,
so I remember early days of the computer,
somebody sent me an email and I accidentally opened it up.
You know,
I had an earthlink account,
those and uh,
uh,
hairy vagina just plaguing my computer at work.
The hairiest vagina.
That was a thing.
It was a virus,
a virus.
It was a well known virus.
The hairy vagina for up virus came out and just hit space.
More hairy vagina.
Thought you got rid of it,
he'd let you get rid of it and then you restart your computer.
Hairy Vagina Gig.
So you would like would a few like re installed windows.
That's what he had to do.
You had to just take everything and shot.
Wow.
Do you remember that program that I think I sent it to you.
Joe Wants Mike.
My favorite program I used,
I used to have this on my website was like this program you would like Cindy,
your friend.
Like hey,
check this out.
And he opened it up and it doesn't do anything and they're like,
what the fuck was that about her?
So like a pitcher and then every time you type though,
cause I like to suck big Dick.
I liked the SEC.
You couldn't stop it.
The only way to stop it was like the hit the escape button.
But what I did is I put that on my website.
Once I got all these people pissed off at me,
emailing me like I like to suck big cock,
I like to suck because it's,
I'm like shit,
I need to tell them how that term.
So you put this virus on the answer?
No,
it was,
it was something that people like passed around before.
It was like,
people didn't think of it as a virus,
but I forgot.
So I,
then I got,
I got worried and then I put it on my website.
They,
oh you know,
hit escape.
They do it.
But for a while I got all of these messages all saying the same thing.
Yeah.
You should have worn people
can use on other people.
You just chose to use it on all your
band.
A lot of people from the message board for putting up those links where when you
click on one,
it opens up.
Remember those more?
I don't think those work anymore.
The blocked up different kind of browser or the pop
up window sill.
It's like we're just barely hanging on.
It's all coming together into one big soup man.
I don't,
I just hide.
Your kids don't trust that that slap on her.
Don't trust trusting the cloud sits the way to go.
Well,
um,
you know,
it seems a little tricky.
I use it for writing so that a,
you know,
like sometimes I'll update something on my laptop so I save it,
but I also want to make sure that I save it on the cloud.
I don't want to lose my,
uh,
the chapter,
so then want to go back to it at home.
I do it that way,
so I'm not using the cloud at all.
I do use the mobile me,
which I like and that's what I'm talking about.
Yeah,
I guess that's dead.
Did you hear about that?
It's done.
Yeah.
There they killed it.
That's killed mower me.
Yeah.
The cloud is the new version of be and now it's free.
Uh,
and so mobile me for current subscribers,
it's going to last till 2012 but it's just been a turn into the cloud to
skynet's going like,
fuck yeah dude.
Did you hear the creative dude dude bro,
it's just a preemptive strike against people in the message board.
So you do know the toy moon?
Um,
they are,
they've created an artificial brain,
real artificial brain that exhibits 12 seconds of short term memory.
Isn't that awesome?
It's fucking nuts,
man.
I think that 12 seconds.
It's just like,
you know,
old school battery life.
So it's kind of bio diesel car,
right?
Yeah.
Al Pulls up in this fucking ancient car.
Like he's in a Goddamn Charles Bronson movie from the 70s,
right.
Car.
Then I have this hobby car and I'm trying to fix it up and I bought it from some
Old Lady in Florida and I actually bought it on Ebay and had it sent out.
Wow.
And it's great.
I love it.
And it's an old,
it's an old Mercedes station wagon.
Yeah.
1985 the last year.
So they do a one,
two,
three series.
And then if you research a cars are most reliable cars ever made?
I think it was a Volvo to 40,
and this car are really just incredibly reliable.
Anyone he knows that he's like diesel engine.
I think.
Um,
you know,
dodge has his great diesel engine that they use in a Mercedes had these one,
two,
three series and you can go and get them bio diesel converted.
So when all the shit hits the fan and people are fighting at the gas stations,
I'll be,
remember this lockbox co op that can make their own shit and I can go in and
preparing for the apocalypse and the family then puts our handguns shotguns in
our car and all of our water and we drive away and go kill each other.
Sure.
There's this guy in la that I don't know.
What's that shit that if they can take that bulk chemical from water,
uh,
in a fluoride from no,
no,
no.
For cars it's a,
Oh,
there's some hot hydrogen.
There's hydrogen fuel Mercedes.
Who's doing those and then Mercedes and a Toyota Toyota's doing,
I'm also like,
they're all coming out in like 2012 or something like that.
But there's this guy in la that we'll put a kit in your car now that like if you
get like 30 gowns,
whatever,
or 30 miles a gallon it,
we'll take it up to like 45 why aren't we on that?
Really?
It's so,
it just supplements it with hydrogen.
It makes it a hydrogen hybrid.
I I,
yeah,
I think it makes it a hybrid.
The height of them mother fuckers going to blow sky high one day you're going to
be speeding.
Hold on the four oh five and that shit's going to blow up behind you.
You see your car flying over other cars before you realize what happened.
Thinking about trading my new car or my aunt.
Not new,
but yeah.
Caryn just cause I get 15 miles a gallon.
Yeah,
you got a big SUV but it's nice we get in an accident.
Suv.
It's medium outlines of it causes an accent though.
Yeah.
I Dunno man.
That's why this thing is said outside is the tank.
It's made with,
you know,
all steel.
Just explain to me where you're going to get your bio diesel for folks that
don't know you can make bio diesel with what kind of food?
Well you go onto the crops,
right?
No,
it's just all day.
Um,
Greece,
it's all it can be.
He can do it with cooking.
[inaudible] our buddy Tony from Columbus had a car that he had running,
I think it was an old Mercedes as well.
There's different
percentages of it.
And so you go by [inaudible] 99 99% 20% and then you can look on and there's all
these groups we're can,
you could search for biodiesel and a map comes up and there's one over in Sun
Valley I think called a,
I'd create that.
And then there's one in echo park that just reopened their membership.
Wow.
So you pay for,
I'm paying.
I can be.
So how are they not do it?
I'm not running.
What are they doing?
Manufacturing process with a,
I know that they use,
they can use vegetable oil and convert it to diesel and in Burns,
this sort of clean diesel.
So not only is for the atmosphere,
it's better.
It burns clean.
Yeah.
That's all the TDIS cars that are coming out with Volkswagen and burn.
Mercedes and Volkswagen are burning clean diesel.
And so
what does that mean?
Vapor?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I believe that.
Yeah.
Cause when my car and I kicked back and I'm running regular diesel,
I mean a smoke cloud shoots out behind me.
I'm not sure if you've ever been stuck behind a diesel car,
but any like Boston's running diesel that's received black smoke going in the
atmosphere with clean diesel,
a doesn't admit that at all.
There's no,
you know,
it's not as toxic.
I'm not sure how they're making him.
And I'm probably a little bit over my head.
So is this,
um,
is this an engine issue or a just wait,
we'll in the same engine.
Yeah,
same,
same
diesel fuel is,
they're putting it through these newer engines.
Newer diesel engines are admitting sort of,
it's an engine thing.
It's not like your car though.
The 85,
you know,
and this is the old style and the new ones are burning clean.
That's 2011 is all CDI was clean diesel.
So they figured out how to do it just by justice adjusting something in the,
in the engine.
Yeah.
I'm sure that they can back it up with gasoline.
That's,
that's crazy.
Well,
there's natural gas cars that are now coming out and yeah,
you
mentioned the hydrogen.
I mean,
I,
anybody buying a car that wants to buy a new car,
I think now because you have a lot of the cars to the United States and um,
you know,
get your V12 on now,
that's a high look at it.
And it's like people don't want to get a car,
a lot of gas by
a challenger now because when it's semi affordable,
because you're not going to be able to do that five years from now,
they're not going to going to be an extinct thing.
And gas costs are just going to be ridiculous.
So you,
you,
are you a proponent of peak oil?
Do you believe that without even know,
you don't know what peak oil is?
The theory that there is a certain amount of oil of finite amount and that once
you hit it,
you hit like the,
uh,
the peak of the production process until the well starts giving out as the well
starts giving out
diminishing returns.
That's bullshit.
I think it's unlimited supply of oil.
I mean you think there is,
I don't think there is no.
Oh,
but by saying that's bullshit.
What are you saying?
I don't believe that there's a peak or,
I don't believe that.
I,
I don't believe that that documentary,
it's been so long since I've seen you.
I know what you're talking about,
right?
Yeah.
You're talking about collapse.
Collapse.
Yeah.
Well collapse is a very extreme take on things.
I don't know what that is.
His,
it's his take.
Cause this Guy Michael Rupert,
who is a guy who was a cop and he,
uh,
allegedly caught some CIA agents dealing drugs in the ghetto,
arrested them,
tried to,
tried to prosecute them too.
He was told to drop the case.
And so he was appalled by,
and he went public with it and he went to,
there was some,
some big meeting and he gets in the,
he's in the back of the room and he,
uh,
testifies and says that he was a cop and a,
that he was a cop in Los Angeles.
And then he,
he personally witnessed the CIA selling drugs.
And then it's been something they've done forever and everybody goes to get
screams and goes crazy.
And this,
so this guy has been like,
from that moment on,
he's been like the sort of like a beacon of truth to a lot of people.
And he wrote a book about peak oil a few years ago that I started to read.
I started to read,
but I couldn't get into it.
It was like,
so God damn doom and gloom.
And then I watched his documentary and that's collapsed and it's the same thing.
So there's a lot of doom and gloom and Brian had a real good point.
It's like he's not being honest about what's happening.
He's like only talking about things that fit into his little version of the
world falling apart.
Like especially what you were talking about him lying about cell phones.
That's there's more cell phone towers and they're better than ever and the
constantly upgrading and upgrading everyone to four g as well.
Yeah,
I,
yeah.
I don't even remember.
That was so long ago.
That was the one red flag for you.
Yeah.
Were like,
this is stupid.
He's,
this guy is saying that they're there,
that cell phones are shutting off and everything.
The people or the companies are going under this isn't,
that's totally bullshit.
It's not true at all.
Yeah.
There's a crazy amount of towers and you know the comedy store just got a tower
the other day.
Finally.
How many stores have cell phone?
What?
No,
I mean you don't have the,
I don't know if you've been to the comedy store.
He was always the worst.
Yeah.
Dead Zone.
Now I have five bars the whole time,
so soul sucking apocalypse.
That's why that plays all the fucking bad.
Who Do in the air and that joint just sucking those cell phone signals away and
you've got to think about it.
The amount of data that's now like especially with these four g towers,
how much data's now it's at cloud now we're on the cloud too and this how much
data is actually ain't shit though.
There's this four g shit.
The stuff that's going to kill the bees off finally for good.
No,
it's just caused autism.
That's all it does.
Is this killing bees.
Do you believe that?
Have you looked into the,
I know dead.
We have a lot of bees in our backyard and my son,
she came in the other day and goes dad a quarter.
If they're not,
I'm saying,
all right,
let's be careful with it.
It's like five and a half.
I am more bringing to the conservatory I think twice before smacking one.
Do you believe that?
Do you think that a cell phone signals are killing bees?
I don't know what's killing bees for someone's killing bees?
There's a couple articles right away when I look out,
when I looked up cell phone signals killing bees,
the first two things are saying cell phone signal's not killing me.
I mean,
it's all that shit's just headlines.
It's scare tactics.
It's one person with a theory and then people jumping on that theory and sure.
But is there a good possibility that in 20 years there'll be no bs or oil left?
Maybe.
I mean,
yeah,
there's a good chance 20 years from now possibly,
and then the cloud will take over.
And you know why?
Why wouldn't it?
Cell phones killed nats first.
Okay,
this is saying
kill bees,
but they fuck up their life.
Why wouldn't it fuck up fleas then?
Why wouldn't I fuck up?
Fuck come.
Maybe a dance.
Maybe it does.
We just don't know.
The bees are super complicated.
I mean,
I talked to you guys about this.
I said this story on the podcast once of a,
a thing that we did on fear factor where we covered people in bees covered them
head to toe with bees.
And then,
um,
we,
we had this like guy who had this huge hive with him and he carries these things
around with them.
He's a professional beekeeper.
And his bees all were met in the middle of the sky by another local group of
bees.
And they had it.
Yeah.
And they had to talk it out through the air and everybody had a back off.
We had to stop the stunt.
They remove the bees off this person's body and it's cloud of bees.
And it was fucking surreal man.
And what was surreal about it was first of all,
high as fuck.
Highest Fuck.
So hot back then.
Whew.
That one,
that one,
because it was like quite a while before the stone was about to start,
was a lot of time this,
uh,
this cloud of bees was like an alien horde.
It's like these two groups of aliens and we're just,
you'll,
the reason we're not completely freaked out by them is that they're only that
big.
But bees are fucking fascinating man.
And if bees were enormous,
you know,
they would be like the worst monster movie ever would be giant beat.
Sure.
No,
they're scary looking at,
we have a wasp again of the kids,
we have all these magnifying glasses in the backyard.
Where am I insect think you catch an insect and then you immediately screw down
to kids.
Look at it under a microscope.
I hadn't finding these grubs and beetles in our backyard and if there is alien
life on earth it,
they just decided to be small and genius and they're down there and we don't
know how they're fucking communicating because this was so
weird.
I've never seen it.
Have you seen a grub up close?
It's disgusting.
Who was a big praying mantis the other day in the bushes and I was hanging out
with this thing,
try to check it out because I just,
you know,
wanting to like look at him,
move around and everything.
And when I was looking at him like this is such a strange little fuck an animal.
Like it's life.
Just like,
you know,
it's,
we're alive and it's alive,
but God damn,
could it be more removed from the person,
this green armor on its body and this is,
it's fucking hands as Jack and things.
Yeah.
Even stranger to meet the horse.
Oh yeah.
Just solas are.
Yeah.
Very strange.
How bizarre they,
I've never been a horse guy.
I've never,
I grew up in the city my entire life,
so I've never been around a bunch of lung and horses,
so I don't even know that.
But whenever I walk up to I'm like,
how is this?
This is okay.
Like look at it.
This is unbelievable.
Like the teeth on them and just like give them one an apple,
you know,
like somebody who's been around them their entire life to probably laughing at
this because you know they have a pet horses,
a pet.
But I don't even,
I mean you have a lot of neighbors.
Of course.
Yeah.
I've never sold horses.
Neighbors.
One lady on a street loves horses.
You didn't a baby horse?
No,
my neighbors,
I live in a question district and my neighbor's got this little baby horses and
they walking around like dogs,
you know,
so the horse things a weird thing.
But people get this very strange connection with their horse.
I mean they ride that thing a respond,
but it's a different sort of,
horses are not that smart.
They're not,
no,
not really.
Horses that were like the cell phones of the 18 hundreds it's like when you're,
when you're riding them there,
it's,
you know,
it's like you're connected to this animals,
animals taking you around.
It's very intimate and for women I think,
oh,
it always feels like it's sexual.
It is.
Yeah.
I just have a girl.
I always ask that question to girls and they all say it feels good.
Yes.
Yeah.
It feels good to ride that thing on your pussy and line it up,
right?
Yeah.
There's this lady who lives up the street.
She looks like she just gets off on that horse every day,
their boots and then they give up on the,
the one of the surest signs.
A lot of those horse ladies give up on looking good for men.
They just give the fuck up flannel shirts and boots.
I don't give a fuck.
If you want to do is I'm going to just go ride my horse and get an orgasm.
If that's where they do.
Come on fellows,
let's go down a cobblestone Rolo.
They always have really rough skin.
Those horse girls,
I don't have a lot of sun damage,
a lot of sun,
lots of sun damage,
and they have strong hands from holding onto that fucking bridal while they come
and they're all a little country,
a little country.
If there's anything that came out of this,
I talked about this on Twitter.
That's good.
Is it?
I think more people are going to use the word cunty countries and it's a fun
word.
It's not that bad.
And you can be Conti.
You'd be counting and recover.
Okay.
And if I was at Denny's,
that's how it looks.
See you had a problem with a waitress and she comes over and she said,
can I speak to the manager please?
And that's what you choose to save.
Say,
sir,
I'm thanks for coming over.
I just wanted you to know that I feel like your waitress,
when she took our order,
she's a little bit continue
and he'd say,
I'm sorry about that.
We known she was of,
and this is your last warning for continuous
country is trending right now on Twitter.
That's awesome.
And use it as a Hashtag.
Uh,
I went to a hash bar in La the other day was the closest thing to feeling like
you're an Amsterdam.
Like you actually that exists.
Yeah.
The front part was where you bought the weed and then the back was a bar with a
stage and they have to copy the name of this before you go any further.
Let's not say the name,
but the thing I,
I did comedy there that night and it was packed and I thought that would be like
the most ideal situation.
No,
no,
that's,
that's an awful idea.
After two hours of smoking Hash,
they're audience is pretty much fucking gone.
Like I was like,
it was so weird,
dude.
It was like,
even the people I came with,
they were just fucking gone.
And I'm like,
you don't even know what anyone's talking about right now would be a situation
where I would yell out again,
hi.
Yeah,
I did pipe wait from the mouth,
come on,
pay attention.
Did my rape joke and immediately everyone who was raped in the audience thought
and I brought them back to their bad place.
Rape joke isn't the best example.
Is that something that you have to think about?
Yeah,
I didn't think about that.
Like the hash jokes are more poop and fart jokes.
I in the future for me a favor and do that.
If they were a you a,
you know,
you wouldn't get it
really high.
Especially if you get really high on edibles or hash or anything super strong,
you really start to think about things that you're doing that are negative.
You start to think about things that you're doing that affect people in a
negative way and that you don't have to do them,
but sometimes you just get addicted to do them.
It's easy to do them to get used to doing it.
You get conti.
Yeah.
So what it is,
I can't believe that's a problem with the why.
It seems like you do to,
there's people calling for me to get suspended.
All sorts of stuff.
I mean,
when you look in the scope of the Internet and it's,
somebody else told me something great is about his,
I stopped.
I will not,
uh,
Google myself.
Like just because it's wasting my time and I'm still,
I'm not,
I don't look at anything.
And there was a while when I did and it just makes you feel bad.
But see,
cat,
there's always people saying negative shit.
So these people that have calling for you to be fired or suspended or did you
always going to be a handful of people that dwell on the negative like this
woman did in the first place?
We'll look up your most favorite thing on the Internet.
I mean like Eddie Murphy delirious,
you know,
ice cream man or something that you know is good.
There is 232 people dislike it.
You know,
there's always going to be,
so look up your most favorite thing and then the on youtube and look how many
people dislike.
There's man,
everyone's knocking.
I like the same thing.
We have to accept that it's not a matter of not liking something.
It's a matter of continuous.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things that I don't like and I'm not mean about them.
They're just the larger,
it's not my thing man.
I acknowledge that there's different types of comedians can so that I don't
necessarily want to be.
So there's all types of comics.
I know that they,
people appreciate him.
Like we were just talking about the opening of the show.
There's um,
people that are just church comics.
Sure.
Those guys and that they fulfill a need and there's someone and there's nothing
wrong with that at all.
Black comics,
Mexican common,
whatever it is.
That's fantastic.
Cause there's people that really like that specific brand and there's so much of
it that is going to niche out and there's going to be different types.
But that being said,
you know,
it's like you can't dwell in the negativity of it all and get caught up in all
of this.
I mean there's certain people that just love to fucking snap,
snap,
snap.
Some people just love to just,
they just do this all day online.
I mean there's Internet flames for a lot of people.
It was one of the ways they get out aggression.
You know,
some people have like really boring ass fucking crappy jobs,
but they're in front of a computer all day and so they just get online on
message boards during the day and just get conti just gets cunt cunt tastic left
and right.
That sounds really nice actually.
That sounds fantastic.
Better contact stick.
We can do better folks.
I know I can do better too.
I'm saying all of us together,
uh,
our podcasts and mine and yours were both on the BBC the other day.
What was it?
I,
this guy was talking about how easy nowadays is to take your iPhone and put it
in your car and having it connected to your stereo.
And he was talking and he was like showing the stitcher app and he's like,
oh.
And then there's the stitcher app and he went and he loaded up death squad as
the,
the sample and it's just so now I'm thinking,
wow,
do they know that's like a Hitler,
that cat on BBC.
Yay.
The Hitler Cat with a suicide bomber.
Shit on him is your cat has what?
When we're going to make a t shirt or that it's make a tee shirt.
That cat.
Yeah,
I need to,
I've been,
Dunkin has my stylist,
so I need to just clean it up a little.
Okay.
Yeah,
let's make a t shirt or that sweet.
I'll wear one of those.
Um,
but yeah,
so that was on the BBC will.
That obviously must be somebody who listens to the podcast.
So whoever you are.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
That's pretty fucking,
that's a pretty sweet,
but you have a podcast now too.
You just got it.
Got It.
The,
that's awesome.
So we're just doing all,
it's me,
you brawny and Chris Spencer.
We just had actually had to put our first episode up today.
We're going to try it.
We're going to do it on a weekly basis where I've tried to do it on a,
what's it called?
Minivan men.
We don't,
we don't minivan men.
Minivan men.
Okay.
Minium minivan,
men.com.
Nobody owns a minivan.
But anyway,
it's just all dad stuff.
Like I said.
Right.
So it's a jack.
It's all,
you know,
my wife,
you the van so bad.
You want to advance too.
That's so funny you said that.
I was just talking to Mrs Rogan about maybe getting a custom van.
He's serious dope.
The family wagon like you know like,
cause it's tough to get like a lot of seats in a car,
you know,
unless you go minivan but minivans are whack.
But if you get a right like a real event and inside of it you make it cool.
Have you seen him lately?
Nowadays?
Yeah,
there was,
it was like,
you know,
a late night in Vegas watching television when I should be asleep.
And it was uh,
there was a commercial years ago for some guy did custom vans and inside he
would show all this like crazy shit that he's got of,
sparked that interest.
But I never looked at it again.
Have you seen a sports mobile that fan?
What's that type in sportsman would be,
we'll take a look at this.
I just remember as a kid,
like my friend's parents always had like the really nice vans with like,
you know,
like just high deluxe chairs and Oh my God,
this is amazing.
That bad ass.
Look at this.
Oh my God,
it's fucking huge.
I think this might have been one that was checking that.
Like what?
I see,
you can trick those out any way you want.
That's incredible.
And people just love it.
These are huge.
That's more end of the world shit too.
That's some apocalyptic shit.
It's a three d job so you can trick them out.
You could trick that on any one you want out of this thing man.
Yeah.
It's got a fucking kitchen.
See,
I don't need all kitchen.
I just want a big water bed in the back of Marie.
We're going to look at that.
Yeah.
These are crazy,
Matt,
to having a water bed in the back of your van and a TV.
So that's all brand new is trick down like you can.
Wow.
So,
so getting back to that man,
with all this biodiesel talk,
are you one of those uh,
end of the world guys?
No,
not really.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm not,
I just really want to be safe.
Well,
and also,
you know,
it's economics.
It's like,
I wonder if the gas gets crazy,
which it has like um,
you know,
it's amazing how they went and had that conversation with all of the oil
companies and said they're going to stop getting gas subsidies.
And then the prices went down a lot.
Do you notice that we were up about four,
four 50.
Right.
And then they had to talk with them saying we're gonna get rid of your subsidies
and then the price went down.
Like just lay office.
We'll keep it around here.
Do you believe that they manipulate the oil and gas prices in accordance with a
world events and elections and it's totally fine.
I really think they do.
And I think it's like it's six people and what they do is they just all sort of
hover around the same price.
So if somebody starts bringing their prices up,
everybody will just follow suit but isn't a directly based on just totally just
playing devil's advocate here.
Isn't it directly based on production though?
No,
no,
I think it is.
I think basically it's supposed to be.
I think so.
I think it's like all about resilience.
How is it?
I think it's based on whatever they think they can get away with.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I need to read an article on this for talk further.
Well,
I don't think you'll ever find the exact truth.
That's what the problem is.
You're right,
you're dead right.
But I remember when Bush was leaving office,
remember how high the gas got?
It got fucking bad where I know people who were like,
who didn't want to leave the house because they needed to be able to get to work
and home two days in a row before they ran out of gas money.
There was no traffic for a long time.
Like when gas were really
high,
because I got to drive from Eagle Rock,
I had to just drive to Glendale.
And so I got on this stretch of the one 34 where it was packed all the time.
Right.
I have to take it the same time every single morning and I could know in schools
and in schools down,
I can really regulate that shit.
And I remember getting on when gas prices were high and I just float.
I didn't have to get in the Carpool lane or anything because that's how few
people were driving.
What do you think
20% down if you've got a gas 10% down,
you've heard her say a number,
right?
Oh No,
I think it was 30 40% down.
Yeah,
because it would just completely clogged up in the same area at the same time
every single morning.
And I remember hearing him discuss it at the time as well.
It's like gas prices really went down.
It's amazing.
Well,
you know my,
my real issue with the end of the world is that,
you know,
whenever anybody starts talking about what could happen,
what could it,
what the re the real issue to me is gasoline and especially in Los Angeles
because we are totally unsustainable.
You know,
this is like,
did the mass of people all in one area absolutely.
Completely depend on their ability to move around and bring things in.
I mean there's 20 million people in La and no one's growing anything other than
weed
hippy out as well.
A little bit because bill burr came over the house and he was just cracking up.
Ally.
It's like you ready for the end of the world here.
Grown all kinds of shit.
Everybody's going to be trying.
If you're going to have fighting people off with a shotgun,
that's good.
That's good.
Shoot everybody get away from my fucking apricot's asshole.
Your RSS feeds RSS got me on BBC.
So,
um,
oh.
Anyway,
so I grow,
I have guava,
apricot and my wife just made April.
Look man.
I'm not saying that.
That's not what I'm saying.
Like I do like that idea as well.
Smarter.
They have a bunch of shit going.
Yeah.
And I'm gone,
you know,
tomatoes and my wife just for the hell of it.
We're playing,
you know,
little house in the prairie over there and Eagle Rock and she's canning shit.
Awesome.
Yeah.
You know,
you can have chickens and shit to chickens are really easy.
But yeah,
go go.
If you want to kill a goat,
yeah,
kill a couple of girls.
You also should switch to solar power.
If any place is a good place for solar power.
It's here.
I want to switch to that eventually.
It's so they should have that as a law here.
Why you should tell him it's difficult.
It's difficult.
We had it in,
in Colorado,
in this cabin,
this cabin that we had and there's issues with that solar.
First of all,
those batteries are finite.
They have to be swapped out.
I don't think they can last forever.
And you know,
it's like you gotta have like real cloud free days over and over and over to the
charge it does in la.
It probably won't be a problem,
sir.
That you should probably get even go to a battery does even go to pay.
I thought it just went from solar collector to back into the grid.
Like you're paying that the grid is going to be operable,
right?
We're talking about some end of the world.
Shit.
If you're going to have,
so it could really,
I mean yeah,
you sell,
you can sell back power.
I know a guy with a windmill cells back power and it lives in Oregon.
But I mean if the grid goes,
you have to think,
well now you're relying totally on solar power,
right?
So it has to go to some sort of a battery backup.
And that's what happened at this cabin.
The cabin that we had in Colorado,
there was,
it was all solar powered and it went to some sort of a battery backup sort of a
thing.
So it stores the electricity from the sun
with the being the only house with solar power.
Let's hate August cause you shit,
it's fucking zombies going to see the lights.
Fuck.
And they'll know that you're the guy.
There'll be fires everywhere.
Fires.
Nope.
Man.
That whole Zombie thing.
It's very possible.
It's,
it's,
it's a funny thing that it's such a,
a,
a theme over and over again and movies walking dead.
That's great.
Sean.
I just got into it.
That's the only watched the first episode,
but it was fucking bad ass.
It's incredible.
I've been looking for time to catch the second one,
but I've been busy.
It's good show.
It's great.
But you know that that's sort of a thing that we get infected by some sort of a
horrible parasite or some sort of a,
you know,
like look our rabies sort of a thing.
Rabies for people.
That's fucking real possible man.
How is that not possible?
Oh No.
Anything with a epidemic,
I'd totally buy into that as well.
28 days later,
easily be the first guy.
Did you ever see like 28 days later the house?
Yeah,
and that same thing where they or any of the resident evil movies.
I'm a big fan of resident evil.
I ended the idea for a show that I thought it was funny,
but no one wanted to do.
I pitched it as a cartoon where was a Prequel to resident evil.
You know how they're all in the hive.
There are underground and he start there.
It's like these guys,
I got a great job opportunity so everybody knows what's going to happen and
these guys are just living their little mundane lives in the hive like that.
There's a gym.
I think we should do it like talking to his friend even to moving 85 miles under
ground or whatever it is,
and we know they're all gonna die.
It's just think of it as the Zombie outbreak as being like herpes and just
imagine that all these people with herpes being zombies.
Yeah,
right.
It's your right.
If zombies was a disease that you can,
it's just like herpes is a diseases,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
You have your main way worse cause zombies eat people.
So there'd be no one left that 28 days later to me was one of the scariest
horror movies and most realistic ever when that chick hacked up her friend with
the machete,
when he got bitten and he tried to say he was okay,
I'm okay,
I'm okay.
And she hacked him up with a fucking machete.
Do you remember that shit?
Yo,
that was real.
That was real shit.
That was a scene in a movie where that we're a real rare where there was no
Hollywood bullshit where someone had to make a split second life or death
decision.
I mean,
there was no romantic here.
I hate to do is to Bobby,
do it.
Go ahead and do it.
No,
no,
no.
It was extreme denial and extreme violence.
The guy's like,
no,
I'm okay.
And she fucking hacks into depth with that machete.
That's a real scary.
Those fucking zombies where they're that scary.
She knew it was coming.
So she hacks them to death with a fucking machete.
She'd been hanging around with them power.
That was her boy.
It floods zombies together.
Every Zombie movie has that.
You've got to kill somebody.
You care about moment.
Every single one.
You got it.
That standard.
And what I'm seeing in terms of zombies,
have you thought about that?
We'll just,
I mean,
any like you have a secure job,
really thought about zombies.
No,
not zombies,
but I'm talking about people getting in the next time someone says they don't
want to get high,
I'm going to listen to them.
That's true on the worst.
Um,
so I'm talking about people.
Let's not talk about what I've just had.
Well,
for me in the tiny,
you know,
I have a little place and Eagle Rock where,
where's Eagle Rock?
That is just so if someone wants to stock to you,
what's the best way to go about to do is go to?
No,
I am right before the Rose Bowl.
Right where the Pasadena.
Right,
right before you get there.
North East La.
All right.
Anyway,
so I think about fortifying my joint,
like I want it to be tight.
Like I got you lock on my fence so my dog can't get out and nothing get in.
Are you in an area where there's a lot of population?
I'm not familiar with that area.
I have a lot of population.
Decent amount.
It is nice.
Yeah.
Jody's their town or used to I think in Marin lives not too far away.
You did this podcast and this place.
Okay,
so he's at Mount Maria Bamford.
He lives more,
a little bit more south of me over on the hill and it's a little more country up
there,
but it's a country.
Whereas Mexican country country,
is that what you meant?
Mexican country,
what you just said?
Country country.
It's a little more because he's in the hills and there's a lot of open space.
Not like you have,
but for la,
yeah.
It's actually empty lots and stuff like that.
In my neighborhood.
Every single lot has a house on it,
every single one,
and we're all packed next to each other.
I love the kids.
It's an interesting area though.
It was a lot of cool people that live in that area.
You know,
that whole area.
It's like there's so many creative types are in that area.
Maria Bamford is right next to like where my kids go to play.
Um,
so it's a bonus stalking zone.
Yeah.
You get three copies for this kind of hippie little bit.
I think it's really important to to live near trees and shit.
You know,
I think you've got to have at least some of that in your life.
I don't know how people live like in like a full city,
like full Manhattan.
I mean unless you live near the park and you can go to the park all the time.
For me,
that would kind of freak me out.
I like seeing trees.
I don't like being jammed in on top of people in box on box stacked on top of
each other.
To me that just freaks me out.
Well there's something,
but also I agree and I like all that.
It sounds like I have all the fruit trees and everything and I like being,
you know,
have all the gardening space and I have all the shit I grow.
But I do like the life like,
uh,
the like the,
of a Bohemian like in a penthouse,
you know,
in a cool,
um,
like,
uh,
Tribeca hug and run this facility saying so there is the appeal on both sides.
I think you mix it up so you can go when you can vacation or whatever.
You can have that city lifestyle.
There is something about the,
the intellectual New York,
the intelligent New York.
Like there's a,
there's a group of people that live in New York that really wouldn't want to
live anywhere else in the world.
And you know,
some of our,
a little snooty
about it and it's,
but it's because they're proud of being in an extremely unusual city when
there's no,
there's no city in America like New York.
There's a few that are close.
But Youngstown,
like if you live in New York,
the only place you could really live where it would feel like a city.
You got like a cobbler choices.
You've got Chicago,
maybe part of San Francisco,
but it's still not really going to be New York.
New York is one
mass of it.
It's so intimidating to people when you go there.
And I feel like when you attain a certain amount of wealth,
when you're in a bad ass penthouse with your cocktail and a Tuxedo and your wife
was on your arm,
you feel like,
I run this shit.
You have a rebel.
It took off.
Like,
I don't want to say that it happened to me.
I'm in the 1300 square foot house,
but I'm saying to somebody like Jay z standing with fucking beyond say on his
arm,
they are looking out into the city and to,
he's gotta be thinking [inaudible] I can run the world,
you know,
or some shit like that where he feels so and command because it is such a doggy.
Yeah,
Buddy of mine's dad has a really rich and uh,
we went to his house once and he's got this fucking bad ass apartment in New
York City with this sick view.
It's so ridiculous is this guy's got loads of cash.
I don't know how rich he is,
but he's,
he's,
he's rich and I'm walking through his living room and his living room is just
like one giant building to the left and one to the right and like,
he's looking at this spectacular like man created artwork.
But his view,
it was stunning.
It was like,
you know,
I appreciate the view of the mountains.
To me that's my favorite view,
but everybody's got their own favor of you.
But that view that that New York City in the heart of everything view is pretty
fucking spectacular.
Yeah.
If you could afford an apartment on one of those buildings,
dude,
I was blown away just walking around this guy's place,
but it was like $7 million or something.
I'm just saying be nice to,
you can do both.
You can appreciate both and then go like all those guys probably go to Montana.
I bet it's cheap.
I bet 7 million.
It's cheap too because he got it in the fucking fifties or something,
you know?
I mean,
I don't really know how,
I don't think this guy's tried to sell it,
but I mean some of those like crazy Donald Trump ones that they have.
I didn't,
didn't they sell one recently in New York was like the most expensive real
estate transaction ever.
Was that a house on top of penthouse house?
Yeah,
it was like a whole house.
It was like 60 million bucks or something fucking stupid like that.
There's a few of those Bernie Madoff style style setups in New York that you
don't realize.
You know,
it's kind of quiet,
you know,
it's Kinda weird too,
right?
Because people can just walk by and just touch your house,
you know,
on a regular basis people are walking by and touching your house,
but inside,
you know,
you've got this fucking insane 40,000 square foot mansion,
right?
Private elevators,
butlers,
and a full staff.
You know,
they have staffs and shit.
I on San Francisco,
one of my friend's dads had the car elevator where you drive it,
do you see driving this bad ass building in Russian hill and you pull
your car and your car gets in an elevator with you in it.
Earthquake happens and you fucking get stuck in this tunnel.
Families crushed underneath.
That's like some Terminator Terminator.
What's his name?
He was the Batman.
There was,
sorry,
what was the punisher?
The punisher.
Punisher has names like you would have that sort of a set on a chateau drive his
car elevator,
go to the top.
Floor's got LIGO rifle range set up.
Robert Urich in Vegas.
He used to drive his car into his garage.
Then how comedy movies where there of dudes that were like Badass rebel guys who
lived in lofts,
they all lived in this weird like sort of an industrial,
no comfort area.
You know,
it's all just,
I'm just here for business,
not for pleasure,
you know?
Right.
It's amazing piece of water.
A waterfront real estate.
Do I at doc cleaning guns blade,
he's got a warehouse on a career.
Remote Control curtains
responding,
funding this.
I wonder if there really are dudes out there that are rocking it as like some
sort of a mass.
I mean some sort of a vigilante character.
I just watched the mechanic and as a good select a new one.
Yeah,
I liked it.
I just liked the,
I've never watched that out of respect.
Respect for Charles Bronson.
I just write the,
has Jason shade them stayed on what the fuck his name is.
Get out of here.
You fucking Momo ideas wore his hat of the new movie out of respect for the old
movie,
but he won't watch the new movie.
He goes to his,
I love somebody going into their living room and hitting a thing and having the
secret panel open up all it.
Yeah.
Cause that's how he plans out his shit.
And it'd be like if you haven't,
you're
right.
Okay.
I thought you were talking about Joey Diaz.
Ah,
what are you talking about?
The punisher?
I got a secret panel.
It isn't in the funny thing.
Those guys,
they all had like warehouses with motorcycle up there,
you know,
and a dummy where they would practice throwing knives at it.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Who automated all this stuff?
I got dragged to the star wars and concert at the Hollywood bowl.
What is that?
It's Joey was telling me something about it that it was like $300 a ticket.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
My girlfriend's a huge star trek nerd.
Star Trek or star wars?
Star Wars nerd.
I'm sorry.
And she's like,
she wanted to go but I think it was sold out.
But so she's been checking in the other day.
They release some tickets.
What is it?
It's a,
uh,
it's the,
the original,
the music.
Yeah.
The original guy that did all the music for a star wars.
He's there and the boys to c three Po narrates,
his whole like kind of like journey through the star wars and university using
all the music,
uh,
from star wars and there's like lasers and the journey through the Star Wars
universe.
It's kind of like watching a wrap up of all the star wars movies,
like live with the whole orchestra and they have this huge like HD screen and
these lasers that are coming out of every,
I mean it's trippy.
It's really like what are,
what are you seeing on the stage?
And you've seen them act things out.
No,
no stages.
The orchestra.
And then you got this guy that played c three Po walking around going now let's
go into star was [inaudible] you know,
he's like,
and then like they'll show like a part from the movie and then the orchestra
plays a crowd cheer towards the music.
You know,
like it's kind of like you're watching clips of the movie while a real orchestra
is going through.
Like playing the soundtrack to star wars while there's a laser show and wow,
I don't know,
all this crap is going on.
So you're watching the movie at the same time?
Not The whole movie.
Just like parts of it.
Like you know they took the music from shooting?
No,
no,
not $300 a ticket.
I don't think so.
I think we got $70 a ticket and so we're thinking Ohio.
Yeah.
Wow.
We're thinking we're super high up.
Right.
But we took emergency exits dicey in our pocket just in case if we weren't,
we get in,
we're fucking front row of the fucking Hollywood bowl.
$70 ticket.
What's c three Po is sitting right in front of me as close as me.
And you are to here just doing the whole race and like walking and then coming
back and sitting down right in front of me.
So we both like at,
you're like,
all right,
we're doing this.
We went deep.
But that was amazing.
If you can check it out,
if you're a star star wars fan and if it's in your city,
fucking check that shit out.
It's a so basically what you're saying,
you enjoyed it cause you were on drugs.
Yeah.
For half of it I was,
no,
but it is.
It was pretty appreciate data if it wasn't,
if you aren't yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a star wars fan,
but if I was a hardcore star wars fan,
I would have just all over the place.
Joey Dia saw me.
He couldn't find any tickets other than a $300 tickets.
I don't think it's be a Honda.
No,
because the tree bills,
most of the tickets were 14 weeks.
I don't know.
I just think he was probably looking for something to do that day.
I probably cookied up to the hills looking at something else.
He says,
God damn cookies all day,
man.
He's not fucking around these days.
Yeah.
Every time I see him,
he's chewing on one of those pot cookies.
Yeah,
he must,
he must have an insane tolerance.
You can never trust him.
Don't ever trust him with the dosage.
Never.
No,
no,
no.
I had to,
I did a live podcast where he gave me some and I fucking,
it was halfway through it.
I had to excuse myself because I was,
I became a mess.
I couldn't do with it.
The banana bread.
Yeah.
It was the last junk [inaudible] magical.
You ever,
uh,
ever fuck up with banana bread?
No,
I haven't had any of the banana bread is at the stud.
It's really packed in and what everyone's scared of.
Everyone's scared of the banana bread,
but definitely do the joint ventures.
Do you ever have that?
Oh yeah.
When I would go to the nine or games and sometimes
they have uh,
uh,
tailgating,
they have a bunch of this stuff out because one of the guys that goes to the
tailgate owns one of the bakeries up in northern California.
Man,
out of those guys not worry constantly about and getting ripped off.
It happened more.
It got,
they all busted into,
they think it was employees busted in a place.
He's got Doberman pinschers in there now,
but they busted in,
took everything.
He had to be an inside job and then he went and camera digital the whole place
and uh,
put an extra security and dogs.
So it was one of his employees and his employees came in and took everything.
Yeah.
Does he know which one now they,
I mean they're,
they had cameras but he knew exactly how to take them all out.
So the person's might still
be working there?
No,
I mean they had a couple of disgruntled people and he bought it from another
guy.
There's something about things that are illegal man,
that just to you,
you can't have a smooth operation.
It's like,
even though marijuana is helpful and beautiful and should be legal and is legal
according to state law,
even though you know,
there are medical patients are legally growing it under state law,
the federal government can still come in and raid you at anytime.
And because of that,
the only the people,
the people that are willing to get into that,
like a lot of them,
a good percentage of them,
they're a little wild.
You know,
it's,
it's tricky.
Yup.
I mean there's a lot of money to be made there.
Is this your new,
I got a card now,
35 bucks for energy for a doctor.
You have a card now,
the new thing.
Yeah.
So they give you weed us and I purposely splinted my,
I made myself like a stone just possible because she had pulled over.
So driver's license stupid.
But the doctor,
the doctor quote unquote ticket.
Oh yeah,
the doctor quote unquote was very cool.
But this time they actually tested my,
my uh,
blood pressure where they put the thing in there and then,
and they checked my heart and stuff like that,
which it was a little bit more intense than normal.
Uh,
but the funny thing is she didn't write any numbers down.
Did you shouldn't,
you shouldn't say that.
That it was more intense than normal because you're kind of given up the whole
thing.
So do they,
is there a certain shit they're supposed to do?
Like check your heart rate and your blood pressure?
I mean it's literally,
it's supposed to be according to state law,
a legit medical visit.
Cause those all look the same.
Is it like a driver's license is different pictures let's this motherfucker.
That's great.
It's great.
They let you do it.
Like if you come with a person like me and my girlfriend gave me,
they did it together and then were like asked her what it,
what do you need it for?
And she goes,
ah,
pms and shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean there's a,
you know,
in other states though it's,
it's tight.
Like in Jersey,
they're trying to make it real tight.
They really Arizona and they want it to be really tight.
They wanted to be like aids,
you know,
wasting disease,
stuff like that.
Cramps,
severe arthritis.
But that's the beauty of it.
Mean what I said is it's completely true.
I like using marijuana instead of using pills.
I don't want to take Tylenol.
If I have a headache,
I don't want to take this.
If I have this,
I could just take a plant.
You know,
people die from Tylenol.
People don't die from weed.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
there's no,
there's no logical argument against weed in 2011 and so silly.
The,
the strongest one that anyone can come up with is the gateway one.
And which is just a,
that's just a silly thing.
They're not related.
You know,
if you're,
I think the gateway is much more dangerous if you're not honest about pot.
Because if you are honest about pot,
if the government and the law enforcement and teachers and everyone was honest
and said,
listen,
if you're going to do a drug deal,
a drug that's not going to hurt you or kill you,
there's a few that are not going to hurt you.
The natural ones,
marijuana,
it's not going to kill you.
Okay?
And you know,
if you want to try something,
try that.
But you have to be very careful of very addictive drugs.
Opiates,
you got to here be very careful of synthetic ones like methamphetamine.
So they're
very,
very addictive.
So just scary.
Yeah.
So just be honest about it,
man.
I'd be honest with kids,
stop fucking playing this game that everything is all in the same group.
Because when you say that,
and then kids smoke pot and have a fucking fantastic time and enjoy the shit out
of some food and laugh their ass off at a movie and hug and say,
man,
I love you.
It's so much fun hanging with you.
I'll see you tomorrow at school.
Do they had the best fucking time?
Why?
Because they were high.
Okay.
You know they're 1920 years old.
Who the fuck?
Leave him alone.
It should be legal.
You can't get some high school kid who's experienced something like that or,
or college kid has experienced something like that and then tell him that it's
wrong.
You can't tell them that it's bad because you run the risk of everything that
you are saying that it's valid is going to be discounted because he's going to
know you're full of shit about this whole weed thing.
Well,
this guy's got this crazy,
stupid,
radical opinion about weed.
It's not based in facts or studies or any results that I've ever seen in my
fucking life.
So why should I listen to him when it comes to heroin?
Why should I listen to him when it comes to Meth,
that's the real gateway.
The gateway is not marijuana.
It's bullshit.
The gateway is keeping people from reality.
If you're just told kids,
what the fuck pot does to you,
you know all this nonsense about withdrawal symptoms and all this fucking
silliness that you hear from people who've never smoked a day in their life.
If some patient tells you is going through withdrawals from weed,
he's a fucking pussy.
You weak bitch.
You can't even fucking recover from weed.
You know,
just get up you lazy,
fuck and take an aerobics class or right,
go do yoga,
come something.
Go fishing you fuck head to do something.
You're not addicted to pot.
Stupid.
Maybe you are.
I don't really know.
I'm not really a doctor.
I'm just talking shit.
Maybe you're the one.
You're the only the one guy with massive withdrawals and fucking Joe Rogan until
you were funny.
Hello shaking because I had read in 20 minutes or it's some weird things with
some people that are like,
like people who are in alcoholics anonymous where they feel like they have to
quit.
We'd also,
you know,
and it's like,
why don't you quit red bull too?
Why are you lumping that?
I think there's people that are compulsive about taking in is not in
necessarily,
maybe it's,
and there's gotta be marijuana.
I have a friend who was sober for 20 years and when we were kids,
when we,
uh,
we both started out doing a standup around the same time as well,
and he was,
uh,
he was drinking and he realized that he couldn't drink anymore,
so he quit drinking and then 20 years later he started smoking pot and he's so
happy,
so happy about it.
Like,
yeah,
it's fucking crane.
I don't,
I don't feel like I need it.
It's not like I feel like a fuck up my life with it,
but I'm like,
that's a crazy risk to take.
But a lot of people like,
you know,
we have some friends that are,
there are friends of bills,
you know,
that are in the alcoholics anonymous program and they know,
he's like,
you can't,
you know,
tape can't take it that marijuana,
he can't do anything.
Tate says the same thing.
He doesn't want to smoke pot.
He said he would to,
but he thinks if he did,
he would just start doing everything else.
Yeah.
I used to do and just go fucking crazy.
And I mean I'd known him for a long time.
He's one of the first people I met when I was down in the end it came down to La
and I think that he just seeing him with,
you know,
his act I think is better.
It's amazing.
I just had a regular at the comedy store is insane.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
Well,
but anyway,
but sales every time we can.
But yeah,
teams,
he's a smart guy.
You know,
TV is a smart,
funny guy and he's been around a long time.
It's nice to see him get his shit together.
Yeah.
There's certain people that,
look,
it's all,
marijuana to me is not fun.
If I'm not doing what I'm supposed to be doing,
if I have a lot of issues in my life,
if there's some unresolved things in my life and I smoked pot,
I don't enjoy it because all I get is this,
this bad feeling of,
you know,
trying it that I'm not doing what I should be doing and not on a positive
frequency that I'm not avoiding drama and creating as much as I can and always
moving in the positive direction.
Like if I have a,
if I don't follow all the right paths in my life and go with my,
my good instincts and then I get high,
I feel terrible.
Yeah,
just,
I just feel awful.
And I think a lot of people they would,
they do is they medicate themselves and they,
they,
they revel in that feeling awful.
They revel in that.
Just the extreme extreme procrastination where they never get anything done.
They just jerk off.
And especially comics,
you know,
they don't clean their house ever.
They don't do shit.
They sit in front of the computer and play with themselves and,
and watch movies.
People don't really,
a lot of people out there listening to probably this and that,
just smoke pot and do just waste away and just say those are people which,
hey,
yeah,
I'm just saying if you really do accomplish something,
like he's,
you'd go to the gym and you get into some,
a bunch of other shit done and you feel really accomplished with your day and
then he spoke upon is feeling there is you feel like even the feeling of
accomplishing something and really having a great day where you get a bunch of
shit done.
Unmatched.
Yeah.
The feelings that you've earned it,
you know,
it's a very important thing,
man.
You,
you,
you have to have discipline.
There's a yin and a Yang to human beings.
If you are completely,
totally impulsive,
you're not going to be as happy as if you are.
You have impulses mixed in with
care of your responsibilities.
That's why I was thrilled with that book and I found out you liked as well and
you were handing out to people [inaudible] Yup.
Yeah.
It says things the best,
the thing,
it's just getting shit done.
Yeah.
Getting shit done,
doing the work and,
and,
you know,
then do whatever you want.
Yeah.
And then enjoying things,
you know,
and then realizing that there's something that's keeping you from working and
it's called resistance and it's all your ego.
It's all,
you know,
it's all the procrastination that every artist feel faces.
I was talking to a guy recently that,
uh,
he wrote a book on pool cues a hung out with him this weekend.
He's one of Mack's Eberly's buddy.
He wrote the Big Blue Book of pool cues.
It's like really like labor intensive,
like marking all these different pool cues or like collected as a form of art,
you know,
and there's guys that are some guys who considered like masters in these pool
cues and this guy took photos and created this book of all these pool cues.
Yeah.
And he's like the hardest part about it was sitting down and doing the work.
She,
the hardest part about it.
And it's the hardest part for everybody.
Yeah.
For now on yourself to get in there and write and it's like I keep making these,
um,
I just had an office built,
you know,
in my garage is detached garage where I can write and sit down and really get
an,
I knew in the back of my mind,
okay if I was procrastinating by saying,
okay,
if I don't build that space and I have a space to write,
you know,
I was just putting shit off and I would force myself to go to a coffee bean up
in and I was getting distracted up there and I think,
and I'm that asshole on a lot lamp pomp and fucking coffee bean.
I wouldn't,
right.
Because the headphones idiot.
Did you imagine if you had these headphones on,
on your laptop?
And I saw somebody bring their full on desktop,
two stars,
big noise canceling headphones and before and just sat there because I would
always go to,
what's it called,
lock Kenyatta or away from my house because I knew no one was there and I wasn't
gonna see anybody ever knew I was that asshole on the laptop and I was fine with
it because I was never going to be self conscious without anybody running into
me because I know no one over there.
But it was still a waste of time for me to go up there and I put it off and put
it off.
Now I built this office and uh,
I'm getting in there and writing.
I feel fantastic about myself because I'm really doing,
if I can write four to six hours a day,
that's a fantastic day for writing.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I don't do well after four hours.
I,
uh,
I write in these big crazy energetic bursts and then as it gets towards the end
of the burst,
I always kind of know when the ride is over and it's usually around four hours.
I've had some like longer more disciplined days where I'll sit down for six or
eight,
but I feel like I write my best shit and he's four hour runs and then I always
write my best shit when I write.
Like I'll write one draft of it and then I'll come back and I won't do anything
but read the second draft for like an hour.
Just go back over it and wait for the part of it.
Wait for the weed to kick in the rewriting to two.
And then do you find yourself when you're in your best form,
when you're writing,
where you don't even know where the fuck the words are coming from?
Yeah,
that's what it says.
Like all that music stuff.
It's like the muses come in and all of a sudden you just sort of put pen to
paper and make sure you're going to write and make the French press thing,
play a coffee and go out there and just start attacking it and put the pen in
your hand and stuff will come.
And it's just amazing.
I think that,
you know,
this is a topic of discussion on my message board that has sort of like,
um,
some spiritual,
airy fairy bullshit thinking.
The idea of the muse and it's really just your imagination.
Your imagination is just,
uh,
you know,
I'm a product of the synapses firing in your brain and you know,
your,
your memories and all the knowledge and the information that you've acquired all
throughout your life and the calculations you're making with that information
due to your own personal circumstance.
And Boom,
you create something.
And at the same as,
as you're sitting down and writing it,
all you're doing is sort of recounting everything that you've learned and making
some rational,
uh,
calculations now,
organization of it.
And Boom,
you're calling that the muse,
you calling that creativity.
But I think what it represents to me at least,
is there's a mind of no mind.
There's a zen thing that you're always trying to find in martial arts and uh,
that that is moving without even thinking about what you're doing.
You train yourself to the point where the movements become so second nature.
It's like tying your shoe.
You know,
when you tie your shoe,
you don't think,
okay,
I'm going to loop this under there and do this.
And then you just bang.
And you remember when you were a little kid,
and I'm noticing it now because my three year old,
and you're sure you have kids.
My three year old is just learning how to tie her shoes.
And it's,
it's crazy to try to teach her like to her,
it's like this massive puzzle to be able to tie your shoes and put this through
that.
And then what happens?
And then you make a loop.
And how do you hold onto the lube oil?
You wrap it around,
you know,
but to you right now then with Marshall,
with martial arts,
it has to be that way as well.
You know,
you,
you have to be able to utilize techniques in a a manner where you are,
there's no way you could think about it.
You're moving so fast,
so much that it's just in sync as basketball.
It's football.
You slipped that punch in before you even know it.
The right hand has landed.
You didn't even know you through it.
It's all just zen.
Well,
I think with writing there's a zen to writing.
Yep.
That's what we're tacking tapping into.
I mean,
you can call it the muse and it may very well be that there's some sort of
antenna and we're tuning into it all or it may very well be,
there's a state of mind where you don't feel responsible for things.
And that state of mind is when you're at your most creative,
well,
that zone of the practice professional.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
It's like,
you're so good at this.
Do you just instinctually going to acting?
I mean as a,
I like that when you're really doing a good job as an actor and you're so in the
character or anything.
And then as standups,
I don't know if you've done a fair amount of acting
well even,
you know,
with fear factor there was,
that was a,
that was a job where are really sort of fell into a sort of a,
a practice method for dealing with everything.
Because I was constantly dealing with people involved in competition,
constantly dealing with all these different little social things that were going
on the sec,
you know,
constantly dealing with monitoring their little stunt and making sure they're
doing it correctly and running on it,
not running on a time.
And you know,
doing that became a real like,
uh,
like a,
like I would go and punch in,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
I knew that it was a,
this is something,
you know,
this is,
it's not a simple,
just sat around talking.
It was like,
it was,
uh,
you know,
it was like,
like a management position.
Like I had a go to go manage this thing and here we go.
And Punch is a real art to that shit,
to everything,
to everything to baking.
That can become a bet.
There's some fucking bakery at the um,
one of the uh,
coffee places.
It's not a Starbucks.
One of the alternative ones in lax,
they got this chocolate croissant that is so bad ass.
Is that what it is?
Is it Oban?
Are you sure?
I think so.
I don't know if it is.
I don't think it is.
I think it's one of those generic ones.
It's a name that I've never heard the name before.
It's not Oban Pan.
It's a different one.
It's like if some other ones,
but it's in La Anyway,
the fucking chocolate croissant,
whoever makes this chocolate croissant is an artist there as zen master.
They got just the right amount of butter.
The chocolate is just the right amount of chewy and the right amount of mushy
and he's,
the pastry is so delicious and moist dude.
I mean it's all rockin chocolate croissant and the difference she that and some
crappy ass chocolate croissant.
That's just been sitting around on the shelf.
A Dunkin donuts.
Yeah,
there's,
it's like everything else man.
There's a,
there's a way to,
to do everything with that sort of a zen,
finding the right frequency motion,
really caring about it and dad.
Right.
And spending the time on it and practicing it and then it comes back and
instinctually,
I don't know if I ever told you a story,
uh,
but we put my son who's now eight years old,
put them in Jujitsu when he was four and a half and they were calling him the
natural.
Oh Wow.
Cause they put them out there and they said at four and a half,
let's just see what he does.
And they put them up against this five year old and then immediately my son got
on his back right away and they like the Brazilian guys who are around the
place.
Who was,
he took the book.
He's the natural.
We don't tell them.
That's hilarious.
Then of course,
then my son had his,
he did it for a while and he liked it a lot because there was always a kid that
he matched up with.
But then,
um,
some highway patrolmen,
his kid who older,
like the kid didn't want was my son's age dropped out.
So then my son always had a match up with this kid that was a year and a half
older than him and just was super intense and beat the shit out of him and he
got lost interest here.
That's unfortunate for the little kid to the other little kid.
Would you,
you're supposed to teach kids like that,
that it's better to relax when you're better than someone instead of just
running through them,
work on stuff that you're not that good at.
But the guy,
I take it back like it's,
it's hard to,
um,
there's two different philosophies when it comes to Jujitsu.
One of them is the sink or swim philosophy that a lot of guys use.
And you know,
we've used it.
I've used it.
It's a,
you know what,
man,
if you can't handle getting tapped,
you know you don't belong here in the first place,
so I'm just going to use you as a grappling dummy.
And so,
you know,
the idea is to take some guy who was just starting out or as a blue belt and
just,
and just tap them left and right.
But I think the way better way to do it,
for me at least the way it's always helped me is whenever I role with someone
and I think that there I'm way stronger than them or I'm way better than them.
I put myself in a little bit of a deficit and I'll let them get on top of me.
I'll let,
I'll try to work from my guard.
I'll try to let them take my back and I'll try it.
Yeah.
You know,
when I'm,
when I'm doing it smart,
because that's how,
that's how you learn in that kid.
So much.
To pull that kid aside and say,
listen,
or they try to,
yeah.
Did they try to really bad and they wouldn't listen,
he gets each gift cards.
Well,
he's a little kid and now he's caught.
I might know.
Listen,
when I was 80 then was,
no,
we had another little little
kid there was he got it and it will let Lorenzo practice
on him all day.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
Well,
you know,
drilling is really important for kids too and that's something that doesn't get
done a lot in Jujitsu but gets done a lot in wrestling.
You know,
in wrestling you go,
you know,
you'll,
you'll have a big percentage of your practice before you ever get to live
sparring.
A big percentage of practices going through different moves,
you know,
going through different arm drags going through different takedowns and you,
you drill in wrestling way more than a lot of people drill in Brazilian Jujitsu
because wrestling in America,
you know,
it's been more of an organized sport than Jujitsu.
As you know,
Jujitsu classes,
like a lot of them,
they'll show you a couple of techniques and then everybody will roll for the
remainder of the class.
So a lot of little kids.
I think that's one thing that's missing.
But the thing is,
it's that the rolling part is so much fun.
You don't want to waste all that time doing,
doing the,
the boring stuff of learning the moves.
Like you won't learn a couple of moves and everyone's like,
oh,
it's just sparks his bar.
You know,
because it's fun.
It's like,
it's natural chimpanzee fund.
You know,
your kit for kids too.
For a young boy,
a special,
it's like one of the best things to know.
I mean that's his big thing of it.
When I come home from a road trip or when I've gone out and do stand up comedy,
he can't get enough of,
uh,
he,
his first request,
what do you want to do?
And he goes,
let's wrestle.
That's really,
yeah.
So you've got to get them back in.
Getting back involved I think instinctually also he remembers some of the stuff.
He was in it for a pretty significant amount of yeah.
And then he did well before we leave.
Man,
I'll talk to you.
I'll find some place for him that he should have like a,
like a foreign planet of her little kid.
Yeah.
It's not a bad idea.
It's hard,
man.
Teaching children's classes is difficult.
I used to watch a John Jacques Machado,
a teacher he used to have,
I think he brought it back recently,
but he had a children's class for a long time before he discontinued it.
And it was just hard,
man,
it's hard to get them to pay attention.
That's half of it as babysitting,
you know?
Especially when they're like five and six.
They're nutty.
They're running around screaming and kicking things and then it distracts the
other kids.
And you're trying to get everybody's attention to teaching each other.
Yeah.
Actually poking and the kids get sad when they lose,
when they get tapped out,
they cry and you know,
it's like,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I've seen kids get really upset when they,
when they got tapped out and training,
you know?
And then other kids were laughing and giggling about it and those kids like did
better.
But it's such a good thing to learn as a young boy to deal with,
you know,
other kids fucking with them to have some confidence.
Give me my security within the end of the world comes from teaching how to shoot
guns yet.
Yeah.
Now no gun in the house.
No one else can ever,
you're going to teach,
you're done attitude gun run away.
I think it's a good idea in a hush should have gun.
Yeah.
This is what I think.
I don't think everybody should have access to a gun,
but I think you should never be in a situation where a gun may save your life,
but you don't know how to fucking use it.
You look at and you're like,
or how does it work?
And then you're dead.
If you leave a gun around with me,
I know how to use it,
you know,
um,
no marksman.
But I know what the fuck is going on and I think you should know what the fuck
is going on too.
I think you should know when the safety's on.
I think you should know one.
There's one in the chamber.
I think you should know how to,
how to fucking shoot something.
You should know how to do it.
I think it's better to be better to have it.
And not to need it.
You know,
you look,
I would hope that the singularity comes first and that what happens is we all
realize that we're all this one crazy consciousness that's somehow or another
connected through this new science and this new technology and that,
you know,
we should treat each other better because we actually do suffer when others
suffer and we do gain when others gain and that we all together collectively can
work together for a much more perfect version of the future and for reality and
for,
for life and for human beings.
That's very,
very possible that that's what's going to happen to us.
Or the shit could hit the fan,
either one could happen.
The thing is,
my first scenario,
the beautiful one has never taken place before.
As far as we know,
we,
we've always known that there's some potential untapped for human behavior and
we've looked at it as Valhalla,
we'd looked at it as heaven.
We've looked at it as,
you know,
the idea that at one point in time,
the great ones had it right.
You know that maybe there's some place in another dimension where everybody has
it right.
You know,
we know that there's something that could be done better than what we're doing.
We know that there are times when we interact with each other where it's just
absolutely beautiful and perfect and human beings.
If we were all like friends when we're having our best moment together,
the life would just be one awesome fucking collaboration.
And then there's the other times when you probably should know how to bust a
cap.
She got to know how to fuck somebody up.
But you also have to realize that that there's,
there's a lot of nature involved in this whole thing and that there seems to be
some sort of a race and the race is between people getting stupider and society
and civilization getting more and more ridiculous and more and more out of
control and hyper technology at the same time,
getting smarter.
People are getting much smarter,
but there's also way more dumb people to know about it.
We'll do it.
How about what the Detroit statistic is the one that kills me?
What's in Detroit right now?
47% of the population is functionally illiterate.
47% of the population in a major city in the United States of America.
That's fucking terrifying.
It's scary because those people are only as smart as the people they know.
How about that?
How about they get all their information from the people around them so they've
lost everything that everyone else has learned.
They've lost everything.
That's helped.
Everyone who can read books,
they don't have any connection with that.
They have to get all their information from I herds.
They have to.
Someone say,
I heard this.
I heard they're going to do that.
I heard they're going to do this.
47% need that 47% could you imagine if you could go back in time to a time when
there was no internet and no one knew and you,
you,
you would,
you would try to communicate with people and tell them how ridiculous this is
that,
you know,
one day we're going to have things written down in books and you're going to be
able to access knowledge and then you're going to be able to go online and ask
questions.
You know,
looking at you,
you look,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Like,
what are you even saying?
Well,
there's people living like that in 2011.
That's amazing.
It was a funny sketch.
47% dude.
When is that going to end?
How do you stop that?
How do you even fix that Thursday?
How,
what,
what does it feel like to be a teacher in Detroit?
No,
it just a teacher in general.
I mean,
you're just overwhelmed.
My White,
you know,
my wife is a teacher and uh,
there's kids that have such horrible home situations.
She was in an energy that you can't like a parent teacher night.
When my wife was teaching first grade,
I would go and help out and go to the classroom.
And then it's another thing when we first met,
my wife was teaching at homeless kids school.
Wow.
So that shit who doesn't turn up every day,
they have no consistency.
And as Americans,
we go to school in middle of the boat,
Emmy,
every other,
so many other nations are going to have more school days than we are.
So we're disadvantaged anyway.
So then you take a kid,
he put them in a motel or wherever he's living and you take some horrible home
life and like a Detroit situation where parents are doing drugs,
you know,
or whatever is happening.
And then he tried to send somebody to school,
you're just fucked.
You have no ability.
And these kids aren't getting meals,
um,
straight every day and they're taken away chocolate and strawberry milk in
schools too.
Why is that?
I don't know.
They just sit there announced that the other day
when politicians come on and they do,
there are cutbacks and saying that we're going to cut school lunches and stuff
like that.
So many kids relying on that lunch for their main meal every single day.
And then like I was saying,
when we had parent teacher conferences,
like in a rich school,
everybody shows up.
Everyone's eve super involved.
These,
we had nobody show up.
We had five parents and of the 25 kids that she had,
five parents showed up as ridiculous.
You can't win.
So now we're all screwed because now we're going to have generations and
generations of kids that have just horrible education
parent.
Doesn't that really hurt your feelings
with that?
When you see kids that are abandoned,
right.
Oh my God,
it makes me cry.
There was a,
there was a documentary on the motel,
kids of Orange County.
You look that up,
motel Kidd's Orange County.
No,
no,
you don't want to watch it.
Well,
and I stumbled across it and I saw this little kid in a dumpster.
I'm trying to get toys out of it and then he just sat in a dumpster at one
point.
Started playing with these toys.
Having a son or is any,
you can't help but empathize with that little kid or would his situation is and
it's like if you're not human,
so horrible man,
it makes me so sad,
so sad.
There's nothing to me like watching a kid who's fucked,
who's got no dad,
who's got no mom was got no,
you know,
no one who's worth anything in their life or some kid was parents are yelling at
them.
I've seen them.
I try,
I try to do flips again.
I start volunteering through the La Education partnership just recently and I
just went out to speak to a high school class at Sun Valley high school is all
Latino kids live in is,
it's not the best neighborhood up there and I'm just tell him,
cause my mom used to clean houses for dollars an hour and then bought this
company and it's not like I'm doing any motivational speaking or anything like
that.
I'm just saying,
hey,
my mom cleaned houses for $6 an hour,
I have my own job now and I get to,
I'm here during the day wearing shorts.
Right.
There's a way to get his way out of here.
Yeah.
And if you work really hard and stuff like that.
So I mean people can do that and businessmen and people that are successful
could,
should go show these kids.
Especially if you came out of a rough situation,
say hey,
just so you know,
came from the exact same spot you're in and also plan.
It's like I used to be that kid with the hoodie up in the back,
not paying attention.
How are you doing?
He used to be you and say like that and now he went to jail.
Angry that when you were a kid that no one ever gave her the option of standup
comedian.
Does that ever annoy you when you look back and think about that?
All the time.
That's why I was sort of using quiet class clown.
And I think about that all the time because that's why I went out to these kids
and it was like,
hey you guys,
there's a lot out of the jobs.
Like I write jokes,
I get paid a lot for,
uh,
and you know,
I just got this other Gig,
that's my dream gig and it's all because of what hard work is through
everything.
So,
um,
we had career day at our school.
I remember we had Bob Sar lot who's a comedian here and he played his
letterman's and he was one a letterman's buddies and he would my high school.
So he played those.
But I still didn't put two and two together that there was comedy writing.
He can pay a fortune,
be a comedy writer,
you mean Sitcoms,
us sitcoms and stuff like that.
And being a showrunner and stuff like that.
No one jam be intrusive.
Writing jobs that sort of exists and the ability to be creative and a joke
writer,
like my buddy Joe Barton,
nick writes roast jokes for people and stuff like that and he writes dirty
jokes.
You know,
do you know Joe Joe Barnett and he makes a good amount of monitoring.
Hard to do that though.
That's difficult.
But they're artsy mean.
Even being a show runner mean top down.
That's hard to do.
Jobs where you can be funny.
I don't think any Mexican kids know that showrunner exists.
The possibility because there are very few nobody's dad was.
That's one of the cool things obviously about Hollywood though is that you can
get an a,
a position as like a PA on a set and see like the whole thing like how it all
works and you know,
do people intern and they get pa positions and then they slowly move up the
ladder.
You know that was one of the cool things about fear factor.
Seeing gods that were based Floyd's in the beginning.
They were like level the abusers and there's the executive producer.
Yeah.
That's fantastic.
There's a ladder of you know,
success that you can climb out here.
Not necessarily even dependent on degrees.
Same thing with everything is when we were talking about is the guy works their
ass off though.
Yeah.
Yup.
With everything.
It all can be traced back to that.
Yes,
the effort,
effort,
intensity at focus slight.
That's a,
the main things about life.
Get your fucking mind right.
Put your effort,
your intensity and your focus into some sort of a positive direction.
But God damn,
that's hard to manage.
That's like,
you know,
we are all born with the super complicated fucking computer and not up manual to
be seen
anywhere.
And so the only way we knew how to use a super fucking complicated computers
talk to these other people that are using the computer and function on the very
minimal builtin software that it has to be afraid of dogs and shit like that.
Yeah.
Look out for snakes.
You know what I mean?
And I think the knowledge that's built in,
it's like so minimal.
It's like the bare bones.
So it is very helpful to have that guy who's five years ahead of you,
10 years,
fuck the mentor.
Like not enough people are doing that anymore.
Even that he might be five years ahead of you in a fucking idiot and leading you
down a same stupid road that he went down.
Sure.
Bad Mentor.
Yeah,
that's an essay,
but I'm saying,
oh,
many of us.
That's the real problem.
You're,
it's so likely they got to trust the right person would be advice and who to
look up to and shit like that.
It's very important.
I think that's a number one problem that a lot of people have in life and I have
had at one point in time in my life,
is that you get stuck in some sort of a situation where you don't relate to
anybody in your world.
You don't relate to anybody at your job.
You don't relate to anybody you know that you're friends with still from high
school.
You just feel real disconnected from them and you don't know anybody that thinks
the way you do this fucking before the Internet,
man,
some guys would live quiet lives of,
of despair and desperation.
It's not a fucking quote that someone said about most men,
I forget.
This is an author that said most men live quiet lives of desperation and that is
so fucking true.
Well,
I think that's what I was so relieved when I met all my fellow comics.
Hey,
these are my guys,
if I'm ever out,
if I'm ever out somewhere having dinner and I run it to you,
you know,
I'm so happy
it's that happened in Vegas.
Yeah.
I walked down and I saw you in any,
yeah.
Yes.
It's like,
you know,
it's like you're,
you're,
you know,
you,
you run into like,
it's like people that are,
that no one else is like that,
you know,
it's like running into a comic,
front to another comic is like,
this is for someone who's the only people I know that we're going to get me 100%
you know,
the only people that I know that I'm like that I'm 100% honest with,
and that is 100% honest with me.
I can trust comics
in a Vegas.
They and my friend Mickey Joseph started doing this thing where they were
meeting,
all comics were meeting over to Hooters casino Friday nights late.
So if you were working Vegas,
Hawaii and all the comedians from all the shows all over Vegas,
the word got out and you would go meet at Hooters in a zoo and they had,
you know,
but like deal and some wings up there,
but
they do it late night.
So 1130 you still doing it?
Yeah,
I think they do it every Friday.
Every Friday.
And can we and comic comedy fans,
he didn't go and whoever wants to go like people then they have a deal on pub
the heights.
I'm doing,
um,
Vegas during the Mandalay Bay theater with Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and I think Doug Benson is going to stop into and do a set that's a
June.
What is it,
18th or assumption?
I thought that it was July,
July 1st Charlie first until I first,
it's June 18th.
Uh,
didn't even know where the fuck I'm going every week,
man.
How much do you know you're a no,
I show because
I might be going to
Montreal and then I might be going on tour with Tosh.
I'm going to figure out that.
Oh,
nice.
And then,
uh,
for a little bit.
I think he's just split it up and then I start work on that show.
I started working,
I got an NBC show picked up.
Oh really?
What's that?
All about free agents with Hank area.
Me and Natasha Leggiero cause I love her and it's just like being able to see
her at work every day.
It's me,
her hand area is comedian moment in Dell and whatnot.
And B,
c eight 31 says,
wow,
maybe we'll be seeing each other at functions.
Like I said,
I don't know what's happening with the fear factor of thing.
I don't know if I'm going to want them doing it.
July 1st is the date that we're at Vegas.
So maybe we'll have towards,
we'll go to the suitors thing.
It depends on who's in town and also,
yeah,
you can see cool people.
Comedians are happy running into on the road.
You,
you don't have,
they'd be thrilled if he went by and he just stopped by for a second and say
hello to some people that would go.
But anyway,
it's nice to see fellow comics.
It's like God to soldiers passing on the battlefield to familiars head nun.
Yeah.
It's like very few people understand what a weird life it is.
You know what a weird dance we would go through,
you know,
and,
and we go through it together.
You know,
that's one of the more fascinating things about comedy is that you get to watch
a guy in the beginning and then watch them develop and grow over the years.
You know,
and I saw you for the first time is San Francisco.
I was at like 2000 I think.
So anyways,
I know exactly what it was.
Is your very first year of fear factor when you were in the floods are really,
what was that 2001 I think?
Yeah.
I don't remember.
And then we worked a bunch.
Shannon,
you brought a heady up to next time and that was the old cops.
Yup.
That was the cobs by the water and it was this tiny ass.
So 150 seats or something like that.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
Great little space.
So it's amazing.
It's like doing those fun clubs where it's on almost underground a little bit
where it's like DC Improv.
It's like that where it's underground.
It's just how it should be.
Comedy works in Denver is like that where you go under and it's a nice little
space.
That place is gorgeous.
Perfect.
But even that it's bigger than this San Francisco.
Oh it was tiny.
Yeah.
People tops and then anyway it was,
it wasn't even that many men.
Yeah,
that's he pack them in there.
Really.
You got 200 people in that room.
100 and 200 people tops and then he um,
match me up with you a bunch of times,
but you're right.
Like I'm such a different comic then.
I was then,
well you were fighting back then.
Oh thanks.
So I was still,
you know,
you have a lot of stuff to figure out and we still do it,
dude.
I still do.
I learned a lot slapping it all together and pulling it apart and looking at it
sideways.
And you never done it.
Never done with comedy man.
I went and opened up with completely new.
I thought it was like I'm going to put some stuff away just this last week I go
in,
I just,
I'm going to do 100% knew from the very beginning.
Brutal.
Probably should start with one that I know works and works.
Then let them build confidence and then I'll launch into the new and they'll
probably go better and sure enough,
yeah,
always a better idea to start with.
One that's you know is good,
especially when the,
the audience doesn't know what to expect.
You know,
they might not have ever seen you before.
No,
no one has and that's the other thing about the daily show in his TV shows a co
now people are going to actually coming out for me when it,
it'll be sure and Twitter to al magical m a.
Last time I was on the show juggle.
Yeah,
my Twitter and you did that.
It's going to blow up.
It really did even more.
What's your new show about?
The new show is Hank is area and it's actress Kathryn Hahn are now just recently
separated,
divorced.
Her husband died and he got divorced after 15 years and then he started hooking
up in the office.
So the free agents and I'm,
you know,
guy at work.
We,
have you ever had any problems working with actors?
Um,
a little bit here.
I've been in some pretty difficult situations.
You know what I think is,
and I can sum them all up without,
I've been pretty bad about naming names on some of these actors have had.
And so to come back and bite me in the ass,
it,
they,
all these guys,
they make so much fucking money cause you know how much money are these?
I mean per week and acted,
it's been on TV for a long time.
It has got a quote could just go skyrocket.
So when you start on acting may,
let's see,
you get paid $20,000 a week,
which seems like just an incredible amount.
But then that quote,
as you get more and more into your seasons,
are you get job after job after job builds and builds.
And builds.
So here you had these spoiled brats that have had people catering to them
constantly.
I've got your Rogan,
Joe Rogan is going to be coming this way.
Okay,
I've got Joe and their head,
you know on headsets and there's food everywhere and everything's catered and
your makeup is getting done in seven weeks.
He's going,
are you good Joe?
How are you?
Good.
You know,
can I get you anything are here,
we get some pizzas coming in to treat you and your dog got tree like a god
constantly.
So there's people like a Charlie sheen or anything like that on the highest
level are getting treated incredibly well all the time.
And then they lose,
you know,
take for granted the fact that I was making in one week what my dad was making
in a year and a half at one point.
And if you haven't lived real life prior to going into all of this shit,
I think you lose that perspective.
So you wind up working with some real fucking assholes who are mean to the
makeup lady and say this soup is shit and can are going around in his defense.
I'll take trow sheen is over like that.
I think Charlie Sheen was all,
I just use it as a name of the people that are making an incredible amount of
money that and also,
um,
you know,
his quote was wider.
He's getting $2 million an episode and as more than people making a lifetime,
well he was obviously,
he's obviously got some problems.
What I'm seeing at the highest level of TV work,
you make an incredible,
incredible moment money.
And even along the way,
most people,
you know,
they're just,
uh,
you know,
one person in an ensemble cast makes there make ridiculous amounts.
Average lottery shit.
Like,
so excited.
But if you haven't like,
uh,
it's all the TV stuff.
Yeah.
You end up working with people that lose sight of that.
Just psychologically.
I think that thing that you were talking about how when everyone your ass,
it's just,
you get confused and you start thinking that somehow or another you deserve
that.
I am great.
It's strange to watch of from the outside as well.
Um,
you know,
uh,
I just did a,
this Kevin James Movie,
uh,
were Kevin James [inaudible],
he's an MMA fighter called here comes the boom and I'm on the set with him.
Man.
Kevin's a great guy.
He's got a,
he's very down to earth.
Like he's not,
he doesn't have any,
what are you doing on your phone?
It's mine.
Somebody.
Anyway,
he's very down to earth.
He doesn't have any like,
uh,
problems with wanting to be the man,
you know,
he's like super friendly to everybody.
Just there to work,
get things done.
But everybody,
like when he's around,
yeah
man,
they're like the king.
The king is here,
you know,
like they,
like Kraft service people,
people around the setup.
Here it comes.
I Kevin,
Hey Kevin.
I'm so my brother,
I think it was telling Ya,
um,
and people were act weird around.
Yeah.
And that's what it is.
It's,
and then they start thinking that they deserve that.
Yeah.
I've,
I,
that's one of the things that I loved about doing fear factor was that I didn't
have to do any work with actors anymore.
I was like,
oh great,
let me do this fucking thing by myself.
And not that it wasn't,
uh,
an incredibly talented group of people doing news radio.
But even that,
like just
all the other personalities,
it can be difficult and people to,
again,
to take it for,
that's the only explanation I have for anybody acting shitty is just a judge is
taking it for granted.
They're not forgetting.
Yeah.
They're delusional or they're crazy,
which is a lot of people that get into it.
In the first place I was reading,
uh,
how many people are bipolar?
There was some sort of a,
a number online of people that are bipolar.
So I just started looking up bipolar,
uh,
in,
on Google.
I did some Google,
bipolar search at funnel,
these fucking famous people that are bipolar who,
oh,
I don't even want to name names,
but as,
but it's just,
it's,
it's just like what,
what exactly does that mean?
You know,
and how fucked up our Ya,
you know,
what's going on out here.
And I think as far as like Hollywood and like the need to have that kind of
incredible amount of attention to need to be under a spotlight,
they need to be,
you know,
worshiped.
Everywhere you go,
there's a,
there's the,
what is that?
You know,
it's another hilarious thing had Duncan said last night and he was saying has to
take,
he goes,
why are we making excuses for everybody?
He's just an asshole.
He goes,
oh,
he has Asberger's he's butthole or no,
that guy's fucking asshole.
Like it was just,
now we're trying to create a condition to make it okay for that guy to be asked.
Well,
you know,
he's bipolar,
right?
Well I think it's a real thing though.
Funny Joke.
Yeah.
It's very funny.
It's a funny joke,
but you know,
like Asperger's and autism and everything.
That's a funny,
I mean that's real shit.
It's,
um,
what does Asperger's son has autism and so
really hard.
It's incredibly hard.
Like you see the like,
you know,
and,
and the stuff,
the stuff that he has to deal with,
it's just,
she talks about it and it's just hard to wrap your head around how much more
difficult it is.
Then having a regular kid,
you know,
our kid that doesn't have any issues,
it's,
um,
I wonder what it is though,
man,
when you see these kids and there's a bunch of 'em online of different examples
of children who have some incredible ability as well as being artistic.
Like there's a boy,
we've talked about him before who can look out the window of a plane as he's
driving over a city and then he draws the city in scale.
Perfect.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And he's got autism and there's all sorts of other kids that have autism and,
and they also are amazing at something,
you know?
I mean there's,
there's a bunch.
So people were trying to figure out what the fuck that is.
You know,
I mean wonder if that is eventually what human beings are going to be like.
I wonder if the autistic super genius mind that allows that little child to draw
that image looking out the window at a city maybe that is a hint of what the
future human is going to be capable of is in comparison to us in comparison to
the monkeys that were our ancestors.
You know,
our ape ancestors that were flipping over cow turds looking for worms to eat
their mind and compare it to the capabilities of our mind is just like us be
compared to that autistic kid.
I mean it's like it could be that the,
you know,
what we're seeing is this one weird thing happens in this child's mind and all
the other stuff gets fucked up and frazzled because one side is like so much
more powerful and one area has like so much more ability than the rest of the
mind that it's just not quite ready yet.
But it's like some,
some early versions of this new future,
incredible superhuman that were,
were eventually becoming,
yeah.
It's,
it's difficult to see anybody with autism because there's all different levels.
Sure.
Some of them are just completely in trouble.
That's another thing where I,
you're talking about seeing a kid that was,
you know,
in the dumpster or anything like vandalism.
No.
Tell kids.
Some parents having to deal with a kid with autism or any severe handicap in any
sort of way.
It just,
yeah,
it does because they also feel for the parent too.
And it's like,
and the kid,
you know,
it was just completely sweet,
but just,
it's,
um,
it's tough and it must be difficult to see.
Also,
I mean,
and I'm just assuming,
and I've never talked to anybody about it,
but it's kind of be hard to see you holding hands,
you know,
with your daughter and me playing with my son wrestling.
And then when you know their kid,
there's a kid that walks around our block and there's any,
he came up,
me and my son were playing catch in the front playing football and this kid,
you know,
went up to the ball and I go,
hey,
you want to,
you want to catch the ball?
And Dad said,
yeah,
he can't.
He can't hear you man.
And a dad was walking like 10 paces behind his kid and I go,
you want to try it?
You know?
And I gave him the ball and then he just should have dropped it and walked away.
And my son goes,
dad,
what's going on?
You know?
And I had explained apple,
just like I watched this guy walking 10 paces behind his kid with his backpack.
Just suck it up and dealing with it.
And it was just fucking brutal.
Like in here I am,
I can go and go deep.
Okay,
blue 42 all right,
cut at the car.
I want you to take a left and he's,
you know,
and I'm hitting my son,
my son's putting
his hands up in the air and celebrating.
And here,
this guy's talking bill never have any of that.
Wow.
And I feel horrible about the chip [inaudible] I can't,
I don't know what it is,
why I was always pretty,
pretty big softy before.
But it was just,
the kids really ruined everything.
I was always a big softie for kids just because I remember being a kid and being
fucked up and confused.
So when I see kids that are fucked up today and it kills me,
you know,
it's um,
and having kids yourself just totally takes that to another level.
And you have this little human being you're responsible for raising and talking
to and kind of going through life with that all,
it takes everything to another level.
No,
and it's helped me to sort of make better choices as well.
Like I always think about then what I would tell them,
you know?
And if you're having too many drinks,
getting in a car and shit like that,
it's like you got it.
What would you tell your kid to do?
You know?
And it's like if they had a camera looking in,
maybe you should start with that passion in your future child.
It's going to be able to see everything.
Like are you ever going to have kids wine,
uh,
thought about it at all?
I mean,
how do you want to ruin the world?
Well,
my,
my whole thing with the kids is I can barely support myself,
you know,
so I don't think I need to bring a kid into that either right now.
But I'm just saying at some point in your life,
you never thought you were going to,
because I remember we talked about this,
cause I always had kids when we many years ago.
Yeah.
And we are,
well,
when I first met you,
your thing that you were always talking about was that you felt like you had a
team,
you know,
your,
your team,
which I kind of understand that,
but my,
my,
my issue was always,
especially then I was always worried about having to be responsible for somebody
else.
I was always worried about having to take care of somebody else and having to
uh,
to uh,
succeed because I need to,
to keep them pure.
Responsible.
Yeah.
Missouri,
I mean,
especially,
you know,
15 years ago,
whatever,
it was very,
very much like that.
Like in my mind,
that was that having a child was the ultimate like parachute that would pull you
back.
Like there was no way you would escape it.
You know,
that I would,
there's no way I'll be able to do what I wanted to do if I had a child.
Very true.
There's,
it's a much harder,
like I go to do some of these sets,
you know what,
I'm fucking exhausted.
Like I really am like in terms of handicapping me,
I am severely handicap.
It requires a lot of time.
But what you get out of it as your unbelieving come such a different human
being.
You know what I said?
You know,
and I sub called someone country,
it would have been way worse 10 years ago.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
I would have said something horrible.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I would've,
I would've been so,
so much different in my,
I look at everybody now,
I swear to God,
and I've talked about this before,
but it is true.
I look at everybody as a baby that grew up,
everybody,
when I run into people,
when I watched that crazy lady who killed her kid in Florida,
no matter who I look at it on television,
when beat me people in real life,
because I've seen babies become little people.
And then those little people start talking to you and having conversations to
you and you see their personality blossom.
Whenever I see somebody,
whether they're in they're kind or whether they're douchebags,
I always think,
what was this person like when they were a baby?
Changed my whole way of assessing human beings instead of assessing them as this
guy that I'm meeting that's Super Douchey and 30 and he,
he's squeezing my hand when he's shaking it and he keeps touching my neck and
come on,
stop being weird.
And instead of seeing that,
I'm like,
look at this poor baby that grew up with some fucked up dad who was probably
ultra douchey.
And his mom probably used to scream at them and you know,
they probably smoked when he was in the womb and then,
you know,
I'm,
I'm seeing them now and he's just a bundle of nerves and,
and insecurities and bullshit.
You know,
I,
I don't see people anymore.
I see people,
but I see a process.
It's weird.
I mean I see the,
I literally,
I just start going back.
I see someone,
I mean I'm,
this is Bob Bob.
This is Joe Rogan.
Hi Bob.
Nice to meet Ya.
Two,
two,
two.
What happened to Bob?
Why is you wearing that shirt?
Why is he touching my neck?
Guys like to touch you.
Especially like some guys were like into UFC.
They want to fucking grab you.
Oh really?
Fill you up
sometimes guys.
Who had you been grappled to get an over hook on me?
I'm like,
Hey,
settle down while we were wrestling.
It's funny.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I don't know.
For the most part,
people are Super Nice.
You know what the thing,
one of the things about the,
the Nma crowd,
you would think there's just way more douche bags and they are the douchebags
kind of get outed.
And there's some,
there's some peripheral ones that do venture in and out of the business.
But as far as like a lot of the people you run into pretty fucking cool.
Like as far as like the,
there's the sheer numbers of you ever,
ever,
ever taken you until you FCL I went to that one in Vegas was me and Tivo.
Marilyn t and that's right.
Who went?
It was me.
And
what's,
um,
Ari now?
I only was Joey.
That Shania Twain?
No,
no,
no.
Either way.
Who fought?
Do you remember the UFC?
That TV show where they had the ultimate fighter?
The finals at the prom.
So we went to of those scare crow guy knocked out the cat.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Pablo Garza,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I want to do broke his hand.
Right.
He just flying triangled somebody in that was amazing.
And Montreal,
he's a,
he's a beast.
Our Kid,
I liked that.
What was the fight over the weekend?
Then some guy broke his hand.
Did I read that correctly?
That uh,
after the second round he broke his hand and he had to stop the fight.
No,
you talking about boxing?
Christy boxing,
Christy Martin,
that old woman that used to box back in the day when Mike Tyson was fighting,
she would find on the undercard norm that the coal miner's daughter,
well she's an old lady now,
she still fights.
She's still,
she just start fighting again and her husband tried to kill her last year.
He shot her and stabbed her.
So I mean this bitch recovered from that bit.
I shouldn't say this,
this fine late once this client to bitch.
I say with all due respect,
it's just the way I talk.
I apologize.
It's just the way I talk.
When you get shot and stabbed and you come back from it,
you are a bitch mother.
And She was light in this girl up and she dropped the girl and then she hit her
with a combination and broke her hand.
Like,
you could see her wince,
like,
and she hit her with it again and then turn and screen and they pull their glow
over.
Her hand was just a mouthful and it was horrible.
Look,
and it was shattered.
I mean,
it was so bad she couldn't,
she couldn't possibly go on Rye.
A favorite broke bolt is fucking hands in the second round of a five round war
that he had with Mike Brown,
broke bolt his fucking hands.
So for five rounds,
he's trying to grapple and punch with crunchy bones.
They're like snapping and moving inside of his hand and he's got an elbow.
The dude,
because he can't punch them anymore,
you know,
the whole fucking foot.
But meanwhile,
he never quit.
I mean,
he hunted me for fucking rounds.
Yeah,
there's a,
he broke his hand in his last fight too.
He had to go through a surgery court.
Mcgowan broke his hand.
I was saying court mechanic,
but there's a,
there's a fighter named Corby coun.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
He won the ultimate fighter.
What is his last name?
Hold on.
UFC just announced today a that they have a new,
uh,
Xbox channel where you can bet against your friends on it and you can like
gamble on the UFC channel and watch replays and kind of like fantasy baseball I
think,
but mixed with the UFC
man.
It's just a matter of time.
Yeah,
of course.
That's going to be popular,
dude.
I'm done.
Yes.
Got It confused with somebody else,
you know,
Corey and Google on it.
Um,
so that's what I ended up going with court McGee,
court McGee,
Jesus Christ.
Anytime you get a Mugga Mugga growing up in Boston,
so many middleware,
so many McGough McGilvery macgyver,
but if we're going to eat,
they all blur the blur together.
Yeah.
What is it about the name court?
Because there's a court Macola,
well,
Colt Mccoy,
he's the quarterback.
There's a quarterback that to the court and Mick goes together for some odd
reason.
Anyway,
we sat and we watched and that was one of the first times I'd ever seen anything
USC.
And then t was down on the floor dressed up.
I was flying just dumb as what he just dressed up.
He had his Nice Dad's angst.
Studley yeah.
On a size on the floor,
like a manager who's texting me.
It's like rampage is behind me.
That's how good the seats.
Yeah.
That's one of the coolest things about,
uh,
having the Gig of the UFC has been able to get people those suits.
It's fun,
man.
Being there live and watching it live is a very strange thing,
isn't it?
It's so people who haven't seen a live fight,
um,
you can get commentary where you can listen,
you can get a little radio and you plug it into your ear and you can listen to
the commentary wall,
the fights going on.
A lot of people like that.
But there's something about hearing the impact in real life as opposed to
through speakers.
But you only get that close.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
That's why though,
but even if you're,
you're
not that far away.
You know,
you're like first tier and first tier like Mandalay Bay,
which is like not on the worth of it's way better.
First Year is actually better because you can,
like,
you look down,
you have a better view.
You kind of handicaps vantage point,
but you want to hear the impact.
And what about,
uh,
any smack talk?
Think what goes on.
Tough to hear.
It's tough for me to hear while I'm right there.
I like Nick Diaz.
Can,
you can,
uh,
he could smack talking.
You can hear what he's saying.
Nick Diaz once who's fighting Robbie Lawler.
And,
uh,
Robbie Lawler was a huge favorite going into this fight.
Robbie Lawler was knocking people out and he's a beast,
you know,
still to this day is a beast.
So,
uh,
Nick Diaz gets into the cage and just starts going stocked and mother Fucker
Stockton.
Oh,
she's like talking to two oh nine and Stockton and he's pacing back and forth.
He goes,
Stockton motherfucker.
And he was dead serious.
He was dead serious and he could see Robbie Lawler.
No,
about Stockton.
Stockton is near Modesto,
California.
And it's walking in place where that's actually from the joke that I have where
I got chased out over a fence and I ran to my car with my jacket over my head.
Stockton Fuck Two oh nine would be the same.
Like Burbank.
You man,
well stocked in when somebody,
if somebody looked at me and said Stockton Wolf,
I'd go,
okay,
all right.
You win whatever you want.
Kilowatt hours.
Yeah.
Calabasas.
Yeah,
it's got all its,
there's a lot of crime.
I think it leads also,
uh,
American,
maybe a foreclosed homes,
you know,
it's not a good area.
It's like
it was the second highest crime rate in California or you go right after
Oakland.
Oakland is the highest and then Stockton is number two.
And it leads the country.
Or at least the state rather in home repossession.
Yes.
It's tough action man.
Yeah.
But when he went in,
when Nick Diaz says stocked in to something behind that,
there's something behind that.
He's,
he's being very serious.
So that's what he was saying.
He was talking shit to him when he fights guys.
He calls them bitch all the time.
What bitch?
This bitch like you'll hit guys and talk shit to him.
And he was talking shit to Robbie Lawler the whole time they fought.
He was talking shit to him and Robbie Lawler didn't talk shit back.
I thought he would,
you know,
but I think,
I think that guy really flusters a lot of people with,
with his shit talking,
you know like when,
when he was fighting Frank Shamrock,
frank shamrock was said it best.
He was like,
I can't,
like he was doing it and he can't believe he's doing it while he's doing it.
Like is this guy really talking as much shit to me because nobody talks to them.
So that Guy Sake what?
Nobody talks shit to me and this guy talking shit to me.
He's a fascinating cat man because he does fucking triathlons.
Like he's really into doing like high endurance shit and he gets super baked and
then rides his bike and swims and runs his endurance is ridiculous.
He's got like iron man triathlon and Durrance.
That's why one of the reasons why he fucks guys up,
he just puts a pace on them that they can't keep up with him.
It's just like he's running with them.
He just makes run at his pace and then before you know it,
they're wilting and he's beating the fuck out of him.
You know,
he does that to everybody.
Man Did it to Paul Daley.
He's going to fight Nick Diaz now,
or excuse me,
he's going to fight George St Pierre now they're going to fight in October and
I'm sure it'll talk.
She's going to talk mad shit.
It's gonna be awesome.
And George is such a polite guy that it's going to be,
you know,
such an interesting contrast in styles.
She's going to kill GSP is going to,
can you think so?
That's an easy one.
Oh,
you can't say that.
You don't know what you're talking about.
Listen,
when was the last time you saw Nick Diaz fight?
I haven't.
Okay.
You got to shut the fuck up.
That's ridiculous.
That's just given some crazy it and how much one of the 20 bucks.
I bet that it's a good fight.
That's what I bet.
I don't want to pick a winner,
but I think it's going to be a good fight.
It's all about whether or not nick and work off of his back because I don't
think George is going to want to stand up with nick.
Nick's got some serious fucking hands and he puts himself in danger to land
shots and he does some stuff that is just really atypical of a guy's trying to
play it safe and guys that are like champions.
Like a lot of times guys get to a certain point and they fight to win,
but when they can win and coast and not put themselves in danger,
they will sometimes,
you know,
this is GSP or talking GSPs done.
You're not listening to me.
Does that GSP does that.
Nick Diaz does not do that.
Now listen to me.
I think they know when Nick Diaz just fought his last fight,
he fought a serious fucking dangerous striker.
This guy,
Paul Daley and Paul Daley,
it does not have a good Jujitsu game.
Paul Daley is,
his defense is okay.
It's pretty good,
but his standup is wicked.
Nick Diaz went after him,
only would stand up,
didn't even try to submit him,
didn't try to take him down,
just banged it out with them and dragged them into deep water and then knocked
him out.
And it was incredible.
And it was,
it was in the way he did.
It was a way that George would never do it.
He threw himself into the fire,
even got clipped and knock down.
He's not supposed to be like a striking with this guy.
This guy is like one of the best strikers in the sport and he struck with him.
He hung in there with him and he'd beat him down and he's just,
he's a beast,
man.
You can not count out Nick Diaz.
So don't say that.
I'll see what I want.
You're being silly though.
I'm just trying to build up the fight.
Are you really?
That's what you're doing.
You're working for the company now.
You're the anti hype guy either behind the same time.
I don't like it when people say,
this guy's going to win and that's guy's going to win.
You know why I don't like it?
Cause you don't know.
Yeah.
You know,
the only reason I say it's man,
GSP,
there's only a couple of guys that I just would never bet against guys.
I mean,
the only thing that would ever ruined GSP in my opinion,
would be a woman.
It's a good call.
Love GSPS a fucking beast.
GSP is an amazing fighter and he's very smart and he's got great wrestling.
You know,
the key to GSP success is that he's always able to take guys down if he wants
him to.
His wrestling is fucking solid as shit.
And because of that,
because he's able to,
could dictate where the fight goes,
he's always got this advantage of being able to make the call,
you know,
so very few guys can stop him from taking them down and he's so hard to take
down himself.
Phikeia talk now.
Sorry,
I just saw it.
Like I said,
first one I was extremely impressed when I went out to,
when I was in Vegas.
It was,
uh,
there was incredible,
well,
George Saint Pierre is a perfect example of why the sport is so atypical because
as nick,
Nick Diaz is the Shit talker and Nick Diaz is the guy,
George Saint Pierre is one of the best pound for pound fighters on the planet.
And he couldn't be a nicer guy.
He's so friendly and so humble and so down to earth and so genuine.
He's like a really nice guy and he's a very intelligent,
you know,
it's,
it's very unusual.
If I was going to have a man crush,
I might have to have it.
Yeah.
He's a handsome bastard.
He's a fucking superhero.
If you had to sleep with one UFC fighter ob GSBI but a smaller guy who could be
the top.
I would want to dictate when the butt fucking happens.
It's funny,
you get some Bantam weight with a shitty work ethic.
I don't know.
A lot of the CSPS being my boyfriend,
you know,
I'll take some,
some lady,
boy,
Thailand,
dude,
decent leg kick,
nice little Asian boy.
Nothing that's going to really fucking hurt you.
Gotta be careful.
But uh,
you know,
it's just such a contrast in style.
You know,
he's a,
the most of these guys who we think of champions,
you think of champion fighter.
Just think of like real rough,
like Mike Tyson type characters.
You know,
like when Mike Tyson was the champion,
he was everybody's worst nightmare.
This kid from this terrible ghetto home that will punch you in a street fight
that will rape you,
have you're alone in a hotel with them.
You know,
he's,
he's a fucking savage.
Should just go after you and he might be one of the very best heavyweight
fighters in history when he was in his prime.
I mean,
he didn't get to fight Joe Lewis.
He didn't get to fight Muhammad Ali when they were in their prime.
But God damn,
how exciting would that have been?
How exciting would have been Tyson,
the Tyson that fought Spinks that Tyson in his prime.
It was just a destroyer going against a guy like Muhammad Ali and people say,
Oh,
Muhammad Ali would have killed him.
Who the fuck knows you don't know?
You don't know.
Relate that stuff.
Just like they simulate Collagen is nonsense.
They did it with Rocky Marciano and Muhammad Ali and he had rocky Marciano
knocking Muhammad Ali out.
I'm going to Hameed Ali was like,
whoever knocked me out.
How is this hundred and 85 pound man going to knock me out who haven't knocked
me out before?
So they had this,
this silly computer thing that did this video games that do it,
but me on Muhammad Ali was like a legit heavyweight too.
Like the Rocky Marciano era.
People were really small market Marciano was smaller than me,
you know,
he might've been like a little taller,
he was like five 10 but he weighed 180 385 pounds.
I mean,
you see basketball footage and it's the peach basket and guys are passing it
around like white guy.
I don't want to say small to me is actually you actually be bigger than me
because he wasn't like lean and you know,
and,
and fit for 185 pounds,
whatever the fuck he was.
But when you think of a heavyweight,
you don't think of anyone even remotely close to what I way you think of a guy
like Lennox Lewis.
You know,
that's a fucking heavyweight today.
and Rocky Marciano.
It wasn't that kind of a heavy weight.
He was a small guy.
He just was super fucking strong,
you know,
Italian peasant genes that could just fucking smash you and just tough his take
shots and come at you.
You know,
it's incredible like the sport of boxing,
how it's evolved over the years and you see like the guys that you know,
like we're in the olden days where they would like fight with like little tiny
ass gloves.
You ever watch those?
Like Jack Dempsey fights on youtube and shit.
They basically had speed bag gloves,
these little tiny knuckle pads and they would just beat the fuck out of each
other and sometimes they'd have like 20 round fights and shit maybe in there.
Every now and then.
Well guys get busted for that today.
Still.
Even Margarito got busted.
He got suspended for a whole year,
heavy gloves.
He had plaster inside of his gloves.
What he did was somehow or another,
yeah,
put plaster and his hand wraps and as his hands sweat and you know,
it gets water in there,
it packs tight and hard,
you know.
And he denies that.
He knew that it was in there,
but other people say you must have.
But either way he fucked a lot of people up before he had that.
And then once he had that in all of a sudden he like lost all that punching
power that he was stopping everybody with.
Which is really scary to think about the fact that this guy might have fought
like more than one fight through his career with loaded gloves,
you know,
it's kept fucking rocks in his gloves,
rocks,
just classroom sport rocky.
It's a hard sport.
It's,
it's a hard sport to watch those old time guys now when they try to talk,
I was talking to my pal Brian time and he's one of the producers and Spike TV
and he was talking about,
they had a,
uh,
an Ali,
a special,
all the different men who had faced Ali in his prime and that,
you know,
they had a show subtitles for a lot of these guys because it was very difficult
to understand what they're saying.
There was a guy that showed up at the Improv when I was there and they explained
to me that I guess he'd snuck in the showroom.
Somebody explained to me that this guy was the top athlete in his day and he got
in a car accident.
So he got this big Norton scholarship.
No,
it was just,
he never get became pro,
but he was going to be the shit baseball player and I'm gonna head on car
accident and some boosters took them out from the college that it was going to
go to and head on collision and brain the image.
So now there's big motherfucker comes in,
sits right in the front row.
They said he didn't know how,
they didn't know how he snuck in.
No one was going to move on and look,
just looked at me and just all he could say was that well she said,
ah,
ah.
And just kept doing that over and over again at the Improv Hollywood improv.
So I'm looking down,
I'm like,
there's no winning.
He was,
no,
it's,
somebody explained to me even before he snuck in the showroom that that's who
this guy is.
So this guy was going to be this the best baseball player of biggest hitter just
of all time.
How long ago was this crash?
I have no idea.
He was older at this point.
He's like 45 years old when I saw him.
So then he sneaks in,
the showrooms is right in the front row and they already explained who he was.
So I knew he was mentally handicapped and because he'd been this accident,
but you know,
it was just poor guy who was six foot six or whatever.
And the same thing with the boxers.
When you see a box you can't really talk and their brain is just mush is another
thing.
Softy.
I agree.
I tell Ya,
I feel for all these emotional,
as I'm getting older,
I was never about me.
I was never a football fan growing up,
so I didn't really pay attention to it that much.
But as I get older,
I watch a football on TV,
you know,
every now and then.
And I watched some of these fucking collisions that these guys get hit and
knocked unconscious and taken off
the field.
I love it.
I'm a huge NFL fan.
I've grown up with in my entire life.
I love NFL football does strike is killing me.
Anybody who could say ever say that MMA is more violent than football,
they're out of their fucking mind to be all these more personal.
It's more personal because you're naked and you're kicking each other and sweat
on top of each other.
It's more primal.
But there's nothing like a 300 pound super athlete running and colliding with
someone at full speed.
It's fucking cool.
Oh they got it be soon.
But the helmets,
they were real sports with Bryant Gumbel that had a football player on it.
Just,
um,
I,
and he was handed a suction thing in his mouth and his wife had to suck cause he
couldn't even clear out his own fucking saliva from all of the impact that he's
had over the years.
Well,
they had a bunch of guys that are,
that have Lou Gehrig's disease.
There was a,
uh,
a bunch of football players that have come up with it and it's apparently super
common for like severe,
severe head trauma.
And that's one of the things that they're finding out about all these football
players.
Like guys who are young guys who,
you know,
I've only been playing pro ball for like a couple of years.
They die and then they do autopsies on them and like this poor guy was fucked,
you know,
he was already probably in stages of dementia and they're,
28 years old,
30 years old and there's nothing they can do about it other than completely
stopping the game in Raritan reassessing it and changing the rules.
They're going to install some sort of,
uh,
devices in Dude's head gear and their,
their helmets that's going to gauge their impacts.
And so when they find out like what levels of,
you know,
impact are tolerable and after at what time.
But man,
if they started doing like cat scans on shit on dude's while cancer getting
jacked up,
I wonder if they start doing cat scans.
How many guys in pro football would turn up to have like brain damage?
A lot probably.
Man,
it's a hard way to make a living.
You know,
people will talk about how you know,
you know man,
it's great.
The life of an athlete,
they're so lucky.
God Damn.
You know how hard it must be to be a professional football player in the NFL at
the top of the leap with the top of the league with all those super fucking
athletes.
Yeah,
no,
it's to see those guys who are on the practice squad who can't even make the
team in the first place and they're still getting hit and making $30,000 a year
to 20 semi-pro shit or anything like that.
Word
judge.
And if you had to compete against Ray Lewis,
do you imagine if you saw Ray Lewis chasing after you,
could you fucking imagine the terror that you would feel really running with
that ball loose moving at you?
I always think about all the time,
like,
um,
if I got hiked the ball right and I had a professional offensive line in front
of me,
how far I could actually make it.
Could I get a yard?
Can I get a yard?
One Yard?
No,
I don't think you're going to step off.
I don't think you'd get a step off.
I think you have to be a super athlete to just get the ball.
And I couldn't even run to the outside because someone would be on me and
depends on how good the defense is and how well they block.
I guess I'm not a,
you know,
like I said,
I'm not looking at a,
an expert in football,
but I would think that these guys are so fucking fast.
One Yard.
Yeah.
I was just all in one is when you are,
I don't think I could make,
I get tackled and backfill to every fucking time.
Did you play any sports growing up?
No.
I want it to,
I was telling a story the other night and it's a new story and every time,
but I wanted to play sports so bad and I got caught.
I was sort of good in everything.
Not good enough to make the teams.
What did you try to mind in high school?
I tried to play football and I should have gone back.
I think it was a mistake that didn't make the football team because I thought I
was good and I was tall enough and big enough to make the football team
shouldn't be.
So I think there was a clerical error and I just never thought it.
Yeah,
I know.
And then basketball,
I was good enough but not good enough to make like a B team or something like
that,
but not good enough to make the team.
And then a baseball did not,
nothing.
So I ended up doing track.
What did you,
when you went to college,
did you keep ending up in college now?
I didn't do anything in college.
I was just the worst.
I would be like,
I really wanted to be involved in activities,
but I didn't do anything.
I didn't really didn't do anything.
And especially in college,
what was your major would you want to do?
I wanted to be a business major.
I was going to go into advertising.
I ended up being graduating with human resources because that's where my
parents,
family business was.
I told you I used to fire people,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I the job of the hatchet man.
So I knew I was going to do that.
And so I went to school for HR and knowing that I was going to go into my
parents' family business,
which was firing people.
And what made you get into stand up?
I hated firing people,
so I really,
I really did.
And so I was volunteering with the big brothers big sisters and I was trying to
do all this stuff to balance out the fact that I was firing single moms during
the day.
Then everyone always told me I should do stand up.
And I was watching like short attention span theater and all this comedy central
staff.
And the a list.
You remember that show ended up staying up with Wally Collins,
all these shows that would wow.
And I was like,
I got to do that.
That's what I want to do.
And I gave a speech.
I was the Salutatorian of my high school class and I ended up,
um,
I killed.
So at 18 or 17 I knew that this is my thing,
but it just took me 10 years.
I started really late.
I started when I was 28.
Wow.
So I GI,
that's what,
another thing that I was telling those kids that I went to speak to,
it was like the choice to have me to do my own thing and work for myself was
hands down the best choice of ever made in my entire life.
Like without a doubt.
Like the chance to go away.
Cause I had some,
my parents,
you know,
offered me that company I was going to get offered a range rover $500,000 a
year,
something like that.
Really?
They're going to have your car.
Oh,
car at the end of the house.
The whole thing.
Really?
Yeah.
They,
you know,
this is a bigger company.
We had a lot of employees,
20 530,000 employees.
So they were often,
you're all this stuff.
And I walked away from it because when things started going well,
I just sort of said,
you know,
I got to do to stand up.
How long have you been doing standup then?
Uh,
well sort of.
I got a Gig,
you know,
saying I went to Montreal and I got cast in my own TV show.
So it was easy for me to come to years.
Have you been doing standing by that?
Four years.
So this was your 32.
What's that?
You did it from 28 to 32.
And that's when you quit 28 to 32.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yeah,
man.
Changes,
changes in risks.
You've got to take him and he's Jeff kids at this time.
One Lorenza was one that's scary.
Yeah.
Down in La with now.
I mean,
pretty much it was sort of written off,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
you're not getting anything.
Wow.
Yeah.
And how risky does that feel when you,
you have a child?
And you take this move away from this,
you know,
guaranteed really high paying job.
Yeah.
That's the other thing you say you were always,
for a while I was sick of guessing it,
thinking,
oh my God,
I had this guaranteed income.
And now with any bit of standup or television work,
you don't know if your show is going to get picked up.
You don't know what's going to happen.
So you don't know where you get money.
It's like this feast or famine thing that goes along with being an actor or any
artist.
As I go,
I'm going to get paid a lot of money and,
or the paydays are going to start to come.
But in the meantime,
when you have a child,
you're constantly thinking,
oh my God,
I've got to provide for those people.
It's the same thing that scared,
you know,
the responsibility of it all.
It's like I can't fuck up.
Right.
I can't go.
Yeah.
I don't know.
There's no fucking up from me.
And so yeah,
that was a lot of pressure,
you know?
And so do you have a final expense creatively stifling or do you think that it's
inspiring?
Um,
there are a lot of outside things for me to do Tai Chi,
a lot of shit that I need to get done and like I got to maintain my house.
That's another thing.
It's like I'm working on stuff around the house on a regular basis and I can't,
I don't,
you know,
I'm lucky enough and to make it a little bit of money where I can have some
people come in and help me with some drugs.
Well,
for the most part in terms of like,
I'm doing a lot of the date,
all the day to day maintenance,
you know,
where I'm,
maintain that my yard,
your wife,
she works,
no,
my wife doesn't,
she doesn't,
she has,
she takes care of the kids.
And um,
so you just do what you're saying.
You'd have a bunch of shit to do.
It's not like you have a wide open day.
Now why was everybody that owns a house,
right?
I mean that's what we need to find out when you have a house is fucking always
something going wrong.
So there's something going on.
Even if it's a new house,
shit breaks things crassly managing your,
so there's life's maintenance.
They'd always clutters what I meant.
What I meant is the responsibility of having children.
Do you find that inspiring or do you find that sometimes that stifles
inspiration cause it's so,
you know,
it was a lot of pressure as well.
I haven't let it affect me either way.
I've just been just as inspired,
you know,
because I get it.
You know,
like I said,
a big,
when I create something and it works,
the rush I get from that is so great that,
I mean kids are not like I'd be doing this,
you know?
And even if I had the kids,
I'm not extra motivated doesn't give you any extra show.
That's great.
You have a healthy attitude about it so you don't have to worry about it over
time consuming you and worrying you are cool.
Like,
uh,
really made it clear.
Like you said,
all the great stuff that happens from kids.
You know,
I,
we go to the park and shit like that and like you and your,
I'm out in front saying blue 42 should I like that.
I love football so much that I always dreamed that I would be playing catch with
some kid out.
And so I love that Shit,
you know?
And so I want to spend more time.
That's why I ain't come.
Graham was so grateful for all this TV stuff that's happening because I get to
stay home.
I hate me.
I'm Miss Memorial Day weekend camping.
My wife calls me up and she's driving up to El Capitan.
That was in a,
it's in Santa Barbara says campground.
And she goes,
the kids are watching,
you're never going to believe this,
but guess what?
The kids are watching and a DVD player and they're watching Jim Gaffigan beyond
the Pale,
my four year old and an eight year old,
instead of any Disney movie,
they're watching beyond the Pale Gaffigan.
They love hot pocket bit.
They,
my son,
uh,
tells my wife he's going to do the talent show.
And he's going to do hot pockets and my wife and my wife goes,
I dunno what you should be more pissed about the fact that he's stealing other
people's material or not yours.
Thank God.
But that's like,
I can't believe I'm not there watching.
And he ended up not doing it and chicken out because everyone was singing songs.
It's like,
now I'm going to go up and tell him Hotpocket jokes that no one's eating a hug
and a hot pocket.
So anyway,
I missed that and I was away working at DC Improv.
It's hard.
And do you feel
man,
you got to make that monthly Knutsen.
Yeah,
so there's,
yeah,
but we're lucky to be doing it that way,
man.
It's the greatest job in the world.
I wouldn't,
wouldn't like to do anything if there's ever,
if anybody ever said you have to choose one of the things you do.
I've been very fortunate that I've been able to do a lot of different things,
but they able to act and hosted shit like fear factor in the UFC.
But as Sony said,
you can only do one.
You have to get rid of the other ones.
There's not even a question stand up.
Yeah,
for sure.
Without a doubt,
right?
Yup.
Easy.
No,
it's not even,
it's not even a quick,
I mean it's,
it's not even a,
there's,
there's no,
there's no alternative.
Now I control everything was standard.
Not only that,
it's so fucking fun and it's so fun to watch.
Like to this day I still love watching it.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I just think it's,
I've gotten to a point also where I'm very comfortable.
I think it was I telling you this,
the difference,
uh,
Ryan was when I was talking about how being comfortable on stage,
I started walking up,
there was a turning point where I started judging the audience rather than
letting them judge me.
And that's how I knew I was really like I'd walk up and go,
are these people good?
I got it.
Cause I know I can do it
this,
but how are these fuckers?
And then I will say that there's no bad audiences.
Like fucking bill Cosby is to say that there's only bad comedians.
Like you need to go fast.
Eddie's and Huntington.
Yeah.
Shitholes dude.
The other night I looked out at everybody and go,
Hey,
I just want to make it clear.
Did I've been doing this for a while and um,
you guys have a student of responsibility here.
Your
teachers,
golden eyes called Z.
I'll all sitting there slunched over winter
arms crossed just looking at me like they were going to judge me.
I ain't going.
No,
you are thinking you're going to fucking
judge me right now.
But it's the other way around.
I don't think you guys are very good
working people.
See if they want to check you out.
What's your websites and Alan?
magical.com [inaudible] dot com I also am doing something with this,
my album than I've just put out.
It's let people pay whatever they want just because I'd rather people have it
and the minimum is five bucks,
but still I kick those people that I'm about to send them my hour from.
Did I just recorded in DC because they bought the previous album,
so I'll just you do it all through iTunes or just do it on my website.
I didn't go with the REC.
Paypal,
paypal.
Oh,
so you can sort of put in any dollar amount you want minimum five.
And I figured that's bargains.
So that's how you release your,
your CD.
Just my own self.
Yeah.
That's pretty fucking cool.
So cut out the middleman.
So if somebody wants to buy that,
they go to al magical.com album.
Yeah,
that's click on the outlook on the album.
And then the new podcast I'm doing with Mazda brawny that's minivan men.
And uh,
we just had our first episode.
It's on iTunes.
Not yet.
That's how new it is.
Sick.
That's weird.
I mean we just,
they go to minivan men.com.
Yeah,
I've put a link up on my website and we're going to crash your server sun coming
in right now.
Awesome.
Anybody see you next?
When's your next Gig?
Uh,
probably I haven't called him for spots,
but I'm going to be in La for a long time and then I think I might be going to
the Montreal comedy festival.
Oh,
so this summer.
So you'd be over around doing your TV show stuff until then?
Yeah.
And I think you do a lot of sets at the Improv or the comedy store of sit up
now.
I mix it up quite a bit.
So Improv,
laugh,
factory comedy store,
all of them.
This a Thursday night,
the vogue theater in Vancouver.
I think there's only the only thing that's left is like single tickets but it's
uh,
me and uh,
Tom Segura and a possible guest star that I cannot mention cause he's under
contract with something else.
And then uh,
June 25th,
we're at the Carnegie Music Hall in Pittsburgh.
It's not the same Carnegie Hall.
Is that Tom as well?
It's Berg,
Bro Thompson.
That one is a Joey Diaz is kind of to what the fuck cock sucker.
I got to bring joy to Pittsburgh.
That's Pittsburgh is perfect for [inaudible] and then the Mandalay Bay theater
is July 1st and uh,
that's it.
Bitches cliffy be tomorrow morning at 10:00 AM 10:00 AM we're going to be live a
very special early edition podcast.
I'm going to get up and have breakfast on your side of town.
Yeah.
I'm going to get up real early because that traffic is motherfuckers,
what time do you hear to leave?
I mean,
well I'm going to take the back roads to get to him,
but yeah,
man,
hell May,
anytime you've got to go somewhere la or on nine o'clock to 10 o'clock,
it's just parking lot city.
So,
you know,
it's the real problem,
but it's also the real thing that's great about La.
There's so much here,
there's so much to so many different stores,
so many different people,
so many different influences,
you know,
so much different trucks.
But because of that,
there's so many fucking humans that whenever you want to get anywhere and it's
uh,
you know what I'm talking about bitches,
I'm just dragging shit out.
Um,
that's it for today.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I was about to do that.
Um,
so tomorrow cliffy be from epic games.
Uh,
Brian Post sands can to do it and I got to call Kevin Smith's people back to,
we're going to work that out as well.
And I'll let you guys know on Twitter when,
when will be taking place.
He's got some,
a per diem plus one plus one for,
I don't know,
some podcasts.
He does a him and his wife and so it's going to be me,
him and his wife Kevin Smith.
Yeah.
So fired up about doing that.
And uh,
so that's it.
Um,
that's all the deal.
the [inaudible] gate,
just use the word and with love only from now on,
I was thinking,
we were talking about the homeless kids and uh,
the kids,
he'd go on to school and all this stuff.
Then we were talking about the autistic kids and all this stuff too,
right?
Aren't you going in athletes that were all fucked up to sum everything up.
And then when you start,
I started thinking about,
okay,
and we started talking about Conti,
right?
Like with all this other shit going on,
it's ridiculous.
It is ridiculous that you would even be concerned with such a thing.
Yeah.
Is Shamed yourself.
Well,
it's just the grand distraction of it all.
How magical is just dropped wisdoms on your bitches.
Wisdoms.
Yeah.
There you go.
That's it.
I'm going to take.
I'm talking about that next smartest fuck.
All right,
well that's it for this week.
Thank you to the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering the
code name Brogan,
and you would get 15% off the number one adult sex toy for men.
And I'll give you one al Madrigal if you're allowed to take one home.
No,
no,
just take it.
Don't be scared of running crazy magical.
Was afraid that he shoots one load and that thing.
He's just going to run a muck through the land.
Yeah,
become a fucking barbarian.
Give up all his responsibilities.
I mean,
when your daughter turns five eight.
I have a five year old now.
I,
I can't,
I don't know more shoot loads in the plastic toys.
200 Square foot house.
Where do you keep that?
Every space is accounted for,
but you got to get them safe sun.
All right,
safe now I'm going to save.
We'll talk about the shit off the air.
Love you bitches.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Thank you very much for everything,
man.
I love you guys.